tomorrow
whatever
e
would
l
FL
very
so
govern
the
given that the date where you want the
what commemoration to be is on the uh
April 14th if uh you know we pass this
bill and it go through the normal
process it wouldn't you know get signed
until after that date so have you or
anybody talk to the Senate maybe the
governor about moving it faster us
because it'd be kind of pointless to
pass this after the date we want the
commemoration yeah thank thank you for
the question yes I have I've talked to
the speak speaker I'm relying on one of
the co-sponsors Ruth Ward to uh work her
magic in the Senate I don't think it
should be a problem but I have to talked
to the speaker and your chairman
obviously has scheduled it for the first
bill that you actually heard this year
good
oh thank you madam
chair uh represent poer it was there any
thought of instead of legislation just
asking the governor to do a proclamation
for this day um we see these bills
continually come before Edna and and
trying to move the process along and
looking at these short deadlines has
anyone approached the governor to do a
proclamation for this
um I'm I'm not sure if they have or have
not I just I thought this was a good way
to go to also allow the representatives
from the districts to be
involved so that was primarily
why repr veroda did you have a question
no okay sorry thought you did any other
questions
comments okay thank you representative
Hopper
thank you madam chair I have a card from
representative bney but I don't see him
here is there anyone else who wishes to
bill okay in that case I'll close the
public
hearing we have
hour
okay
the I beg your
pardon no the only objection that has
been has been raised is first that the
governor can declare a proclamation on
his own which is our standing principle
and the other is that it will have to be
fast-tracked through both the house and
the Senate other than that you know it's
a one-time event not a
uh not a perennial so that's a little
less
objectionable
if you're ready to make a
motion I'd be happy to make a motion if
if the committee would uh wouldn't mind
executing this
now okay um in that case since we're
here we have posted that we we can exec
a bill I'm
only if it turns out that it's something
that we need that we start debating I'm
going to
delay the exact session until a further
time but if it's obvious what we want to
do then we'll we can continue represent
goalie thank you madam chair I
just feel that we've gone and told other
folks to reach out to the governor for a
proclamation versus going this route and
I just feel uncomfortable putting this
one out through without a debate um when
we've done this with other pieces of
legislation thank you
all right in that case since there is an
objection we'll hold this off and
execute with our other bills at a
scheduled
date we we I have posted every day that
we can EXA but I would just as rather
not unless it's totally obvious to
everybody what we want to do with the
bill so in this case we have a we have a
break and use it
wisely
happy New
here yeah it's sometimes you've been
around long enough Peter when when after
a hearing long when we sit there we
finish the hearing and we look at each
other and say we know what we're going
to do with this oh I totally agree Madam
chair I totally agree with that
principle uh and this is we know each
other well enough now to to kind
of I'm I'm not uncomfortable with the
idea of this event being celebrated but
I think representative Goldie's uh view
is uh that we we can get the governor to
be on board with us almost certainly not
exactly
spe
get
e
met just assum
not just want to say
hi do that I don't we ever met in just
you on my little screen well have but
whatever thank you glad to be
here so what was your
temperature that was minus two
was yeah well it was pretty cool and a
win I'm counting on the oil truck coming
bit
AB
how you
again
probably
heard
points
it's
some
there
that
Serv
un
those
yeah
e
C
we
they
l
ch
yes welcome to the committee well thank
you wish it was a little warmer out
there
but
son
yes
B
it when I went
to
insurance
that's
states
are
s
got
okay that's good because I don't want to
carry this
my
one
down
you
think
e
anyway
are
yes
am I'm
good I we did we talked about this at
the board so that's that's where the
from
e
s
do we all have a
CH
Biffy
till
all right good morning we have reached
945 and I'm opening the hearing on House
Bill
1566 and I call repr representive
sponsor good morning Madam chairwoman um
it's good to see everyone in this
committee again um it was nice to serve
with you a couple years ago and it's
nice it's a pleasure to be back here to
talk to you today I'm introducing the
bill 1566 on behalf of Representative
James Murphy who could not be here today
so what I'd like to go forward with is
that for the record
my name is representative Gary Merchant
Sullivan County District
4 which is W two in Claremont New
Hampshire I come before this committee
to introduce House Bill 1566 on behalf
of Representative James Murphy who
couldn not be here
today in 2020 A legislature created RSA
21bb which established the prescription
drug affordability board the intent of
legislation was for the board to
determine annual payer spending targets
for prescription drugs develop and
Implement policies and procedures for
the collection of prescription drug
price data and Implement a registry of
VAR stakeholders in the pharmacy supply
chain as manufacturers Pharmacy benefit
managers drug
wholesalers all necessary and also to
assess them a reasonable user assessment
fee which would fund the board this
board is funded by assessment fee is not
coming out of the general treasury at
all the general fund it's self funded
the board met several times during
2021 during board meetings the board
became aware of the need to revise
certain sections of RSA 21bb
specifically the sections related to
Staffing and the need to establish a
onlaps fund to support the
board after creating the LSR House Bill
1566 representative Murphy and I learned
of the need to revise Health Bill 1566
so we're introducing an amendment to
address these
issues the amendment clarifies the
appointment and pay grade of the
executive director that this individual
serves the board excuse me this is
amendment
202200 41h and I believe all members of
the committee have received a copy it
replaces the entire
Bill correct
so thank you for having enough
copies thank you madam
chair so basically what was changed in
the amendment from the original
underlying bill was the fact that we
were told to be clear that we should
insert into the statute the word staff
as well as executive director so the
executive director would be unclassified
appointed by the board and serves at the
pleasure of the board but because the
original Bill did not include the word
staff we are advised to use the word
staff staff in the underlying RSA as
well and the other one was the question
of the non-aps fund was the fact that
this board will
straddle budget State budgets so in
order to be sure that we have long-term
Commandments on the ability to fund the
longterm commitments we wanted to create
a non-aps fund to support the board that
was also an advice from um
Finance in the
HHS
so for these Reasons I'm asking the
board sorry asking this committee to
support the amendment to houseal Bill
1566 and with that I'll close my opening
statement and take and address questions
thank you um questions from the
committee representative Pearson thank
you madam chair and thank you
representative Merchants good to see you
back
here the the fund I know this is going
to sound like a funny question um how is
the fund funded but the fund that you
speak of is this also going to
be um funded
through the fee process and the
self-sufficiency of of the board and not
the general uh general fund that's
correct what we found out is that when
we started to issue the assessment fees
this year that there was no place to
park the money because there was no fund
created to receive it so what's
happening is we're actually going to
fiscal committee to ask for a supplement
to the budget so we can create a line
item in the budget to receive the funds
so the answer question is yes the board
is self-funded through the assessment
fees it does nothing to do with General
treasury general fund at all can I have
a followup Madam chair the the
dispersion of those funds from this from
this um
allocation but that you're doing by fees
who who decides how that money is
allocated out of that fund it's decided
by the board by the board okay great
thank
you other questions rep representative
goalie thank you madam chair and thank
you for coming before us with this uh
just a quick question on
the uh execut executive director in the
pay grade has this gone before the JCC
joint committee on employee
classification or is this what is
currently in statute for this pay I'm
not sure if it went there specifically
but I did go through the process with
the state
um human resource department and they're
the ones that vetted it and I'll turn it
over because I my apologies too because
I also brought someone from the
Department of Health Human Services
attorney Barry Who's acting as Lia on to
us so maybe he can speak to that
question than I
can
uh good morning for the record my name
is Robert Barry I'm an attorney with the
Department of Health and Human Services
um in my role here today I am the
liaison between the department and the
board uh the board is administratively
attached to the Department of Health and
Human Services uh so I'm helping uh with
the board's uh standup process so to
speak uh to answer your question it has
not gone before jce at this point um and
um I forget the second part of your
question
that was my main question just wondering
if this has been approved by them or if
this pay grade or where that pay grade
came from so I can speak to that a
little bit um throughout the process of
us trying to figure out um where best to
um put the pay grade of an executive
director we've learned that it requires
someone with an enormous amount of uh
skill um my words have been that it's a
bit of a
unicorn among uh other prescription drug
affordability boards uh throughout the
United States so in order to be
competitive and ensure we attracted
qualified candidates we thought that the
best approach would be to move the
position into an unclassified position
grade rep representative Schmidt and
then
scitech thank you madam chair uh
representative scitec and I are on the
jcec uh and so my question is um you
said it has not gone before the JCC but
has it been presented to das for
inclusion in the uh next meeting of the
JCC uh I do not believe it has been but
I can follow up on that okay because uh
that you got to get it in the in the
chair
um I'm reluctant to see you put this in
statute I don't know what the proper
procedure is but this goes you the
department makes a recommendation it
comes back from our Consulting Group and
then we appr JC approves it and then
it's then subsequently put into the U
into legislation so as it stands I'm not
in I don't this is this is the process
is suspect I don't know what the right
process is but it's not to put the grade
in
uh by Fiat into the legislation without
consultant Madame chair if I
may as far as the process goes um if we
bring it to the committee for review is
there still time to put it in the
statute after the review my concern
would be that we
have a position created that's
unclassified but it doesn't go into stat
statute and therefore we have to wait
another year for it to go in the statute
okay represent please to explain what
would happen is JCC would presumably
approve a
reasonable recommendation by the
department ratified by the uh our group
cor fery hay and it would be we would
appr JCC would approve it subsequently
being then incorporated into the statute
but it would actually ex it would be
effective before that thank you
represent citech what it would if it's
okay with the committee is go back to O
OS and ask for an amendment to amend
this to come up with some thank you will
we'll consider it along with any other
amendments we think
necessary
um how I yes representative
fellows thank you madam chair can you
tell me about any um comparable
positions to this um I I found job
descriptions in the classified section
for an executive director of The Board
of Medicine and another one for the
Board of Nursing can you compare this
position and tell me how it's different
and and what and who is currently
filling those two positions at what sort
of classification uh I don't have it in
front of me but I believe they are uh
35s perhaps a little bit lower 35 is the
highest labor grade in classified
Service uh I do not know the individuals
who are currently occupying um those um
those positions U but the shift
unclassified really came after um the
board had um met with uh the executive
director of the Maryland uh prescription
drug affordability board um and talking
to him about his classific or his
qualifications and his experiences he
was um again to go back to my my unicorn
phraseology uh he was a pharmacist and
an attorney um and it was a um um it's
something I've never seen before quite
honestly uh so we suspected that in
order to get a quality executive
director we would have to put the pay at
a fairly uh High rate and um in order to
qualifications other questions I have
one
do you know how much these assessments
amount to every
year yes the assessments have a floor of
$500 per
entity um when you start dealing with a
pvm it deals with billions of dollars
and wholesalers that run into billions
of dollars the manufacturers are the
billions of dollars excuse me represent
Merchant what I meant was when you add
up the fees from each how much money are
we putting into this dedicated fund
every year we're thinking it's probably
going to be between 300
$350,000 and most of that's going to go
to salaries and it's going to be the
executive director along with some of
the support staff which are probably a
administrative assistant and potentially
an analyst which is what has been common
in some of the other
boards thank you y sorry are there any
other questions from the committee
representative
Schmid thank you madam chair Mr Barry uh
are you is one time appearance or are
you going to be one of our go-to people
with regard to such issues before you're
with HHS I understand yes I'm with HHS
uh currently uh my official title is I'm
a general counsel specialist I'm the um
General Council to the division of
Medicaid um but I uh am assuming a role
as a liaison between um the department
and uh prescription R affordability
board for at least the foreseeable
future um so um to answer your question
I would believe that that yes I would be
the go-to guy at this point in time okay
can you spell your last name and say
your first name again oh it's uh Robert
and my last name is Barry uh like a
strawberry b e r r y okay thank you and
laugh that's thank you Mr Barry any
other questions from the
committee all right seeing none thank
you representative Merchant Mr Barry
thank you madam chairman
thank you is there anyone else who
1566 seeing none I'll close the public
1566 and I apologize to the committee
for thinking these bills were more
difficult than they would be we have
break
e
House Bill 1566 is going to go to
representative Le's
subcommittee and the sub the two the two
bills we are going to hear before lunch
that is House Bill 1273 and
1581 are going to go to representative
yakubovich's
subcommittee um I will be posting in our
office and hopefully on our the website
who the members of all the subcommittees
are yes repres
fellows did didn't Oh I thought you
already know that any
free intellectual property in particular
free software remains
free
um so yes it is a copyright
um was worried about what might happen
with those so I think it's very
important in cases of things like that
to be able to inspect the source code
used to run them to make sure that it's
not being used for nefarious purposes or
anything and then the last section um
the right to examine uh source code so
this is another part that the um
Amendment touches
um
so uh the amendment strikes the word
proprietary from here um originally I
included the word proprietary because I
thought it would be obvious that um you
have the right to inspect source code of
free and open source software project
but um one person giving
feedback seem to think that there might
be a loophole where someone might come
up with a free software license
that is free except for allowing you to
um except for this particular case so um
this is something
that um this is actually something that
judges have ruled defendants have the
right to do in certain cases um there's
some news articles I can send to you
about um cases where judges have ruled
that a
defendant has a right to um examine
source code so like if there's DNA DNA
testing software that's WR in such a way
that it's biased against a defendant the
defendant should be able
to check that out and um see if it
affected their case at all um to make
sure that only reliable evidence
is being used in that
case so that's what made it into the
bill um I had another a number of other
ideas that didn't make it in just
because um out of
uncertainty as to whether it was the
domain of uh federal or state law um
since since copyright is generally
federal law
um was worried that some of it might not
fit here but my thinking was that
since um what what mostly stay in is
contract stuff which my understanding is
that contracts are handled at the state
law and can be done
here so um that's why that's done here
um so and yeah there's another open
source
coming up after this um which I'll also
be testifying to and um I'll get into
the similarities and differences between
them uh during that
testimony thank you that's the
appropriate time to do so thank you
representative Gallagher are there any
questions from the
Pearson Okay so
so that that's a lot to
absorb
the when you're I am not a uh I'm not a
software guy at all so I'm G to I'm
trying to navigate the road you're
Paving here in front of me um one of the
one of the overwhelming functions of
government is to collect data right we
collect data on everything so if I'm
here you want to put into St statute a
preference to go
towards open source or free software
over something that's proprietary that's
that becomes a preference in law am iing
that right yeah um so you're talking
about if you're talking about data
collection I'd like to make sure we draw
a distinction here
between um data and code um
so even if we're using free and open
source
software to process process this data
and storing it in open formats the data
itself can still can and should still
remain private um so um in fact there is
free and open source software designed
specifically for um privacy
protections um so yeah that um that
might be one concern people have um
about oh is this going to lead to data
exposures but um realistically it should
actually help prect data better
since uh by having the source code
available we can check to make sure that
the software isn't leaking it to whoever
made it it isn't phoning home to
Microsoft and
sending uh sending data to them or
something or
um and if there's a bug in it what uh
one advantage of free and open source
software is that it makes it easier for
uh people
to uh
contribute uh security patches
themselves when uh a bug is discovered
um so most free open source software
just due to how many eyeballs have been
looking at it from around the world is
already pretty well checked for um
ensuring that it protects data
privacy and things like
that okay we'll follow up Madam
so people make a lot of money developing
software the government buys software
for various reasons because it meets
criteria or performs a function that the
government's looking to accomplish
here ex can you do you have an idea of
how if if the state of New Hampshire as
an example the department of safety the
Bureau of EMS will use them as an
example they collect a tremendous amount
of data if they go into a an open or
free software who handles their tech
support who handles their updates who
handles their problems because if you're
not making any money doing this and
there's no Financial incentive how is
the government supposed to after
accepting what you're what you're
funneling here H how are we supposed to
rely on
that that sort of uh service for a
product that's free so um yeah that's a
great question it's another case where
uh the distinction between Libre and
graus comes into play again you can
actually sell free software for money
and in fact there are companies that do
so red hat for instance is a big one and
even if it's not actually selling the
software itself you can still uh buy
support contracts separately
from companies that do the majority of
contribution to uh these projects um
and um yeah that um there there there
are lots of big companies that do have
profit incentives in making sure that um
free and open
source
software works because they use a lot of
too what Bill what problem does this
bill solve what happens if this doesn't
if this bill weren't introduced what's
what would happen
well it it would mean that
um big big tech companies that make
proprietary software would be continued
to allow to be allowed to violate users
freedoms um there's a lot of anger
bipartisan anger out there at Big Tech
lately for being too
powerful for um you know on the
left you hear people not big Tech just
for being too big and then on the right
you hear at Big
tech people being met at Big tech for
censoring them so um I
think this bill helps address the
problem of big Tech being too powerful
and um helps put the power back into the
hands of the everyday
users to use and modify
software as they want to rather than as
to um are there any other questions from
the
fellows I have a question about the non-
compete it's on on the first page um
line
23 so
so you know it seems to me this modifies
an RSA that's not really in the same
section as most of the rest of this it
seems to be suggesting that if somebody
works for a company and in and develops
software for them that they should be
allowed to share that
software in a in a um
free what do you call this in in a free
software environment like take the code
so well it it doesn't mean literally
copying and pasting it it just means
that they can then like even
um it it's it's not it doesn't let the
um
it doesn't let the um employees take the
proprietary software and then make it
nonproprietary it just lets them work on
both proprietary software and free and
open source software at the same time if
they want to um like they can have the
knowledge they gained from working on
one and use that to contribute to the
other but I'm I'm pretty sure it
shouldn't do anything about
actually changing the license of
anything involved um
the so somebody who's doing programming
for BAE
Systems and understands you know
the you know
the defense systems and that are being
developed by them because they
understand that
code they can go to another free open
software place and put that code in
because in their brain they they know
how to replicate it because they wrote
it the first time around correct uh yeah
thank
you uh I have two questions first
there's no fiscal note do you imagine
this is not going to cost anything
um so yeah I'm not so I'm a freshman
representative here I'm not not really
sure um how the whole fiscal note
process works yet um so
um yeah I'm not sure if it will cost
anything yet it could very well cost
something just since I'm creating extra
work for the Department of it here um
but
as we heard uh back during the Iraq War
One motto that was repeated a lot was
Freedom isn't free and while I disagreed
with its application in that specific
case I do think it applies here is that
we we may very well have to spend money
hiring programmers to help make this
transition to free and open source
software actually happen thank you that
makes
sense I think that's actually my second
second question as well other
questions all right thank you very much
representative
Gallagher thank you and I call represent
gay good morning Madame chair uh members
of the committee um for the record my
name is Dennis goule I'm the
commissioner of the Department of
Information
Technology um today I am speaking in
opposition to House Bill
1273 um I uh I have responsibility and
authority over executive branch it stuff
but I think that um I feel strongly that
a lot of these principles would apply to
the other branches of government and the
Secretary of State's office as well
start out with just a little background
then we'll go into the meat of it um um
the state of New Hampshire does make
extensive use of open- source software
for citizen service purposes some
examples are our web content management
platform our Learning Management
specifically uh fire academy outwardly
facing to uh a learning very economical
Linux operating systems as the uh Bill
sponsor mentioned Red Hat uh we have
literally hundreds of those in operation
today um and approximately 85% of all
state of New Hampshire Technology
Solutions contain one or more open-
Source
Library doit also uses open source tools
to manage several aspects of our own
internal
environment the state of New Hampshire's
procurement process does allow for the
use of Open Source software in a
competitive bidding scenario if the
proposed open- Source solution is the
winning proposal based on functionality
and capability fully loaded cost
compliance with cyber security privacy
access to Federal funding streams State
Statute and third party like payment
card industry
requirements ability to agree to
important contract terms like
indemnification and long-term
supportability I oppose hb1 1273 because
it's not necessary our procurement
process and vetting handles a lot of
what the concerns that that arise and if
passed will in increase cost harm our
cyber security and citizen data privacy
posture create risks for federal funding
streams and in many cases do a less
capable job of meeting citizen
functionality
requirements I'll go through each of
those individually but not not too not
not too long
winded um increase cost often
open-source software as uh R Pearson uh
pointed out must be supported by the
staff that implements it that support
does not benefit from the economies of
scale that that a large commercial
software company can achieve by
supporting a large base uh supporting a
larger open source footprint would
require adding doit staff to accomplish
implementation support and compliance
and as many of you know um the single
largest expense in my budget single
largest line item is the salaries and
benefits lines um I I have a lot of
experience running open source in my
career and um you know that that can't
be overlooked particularly when you're
talking about actually looking at the
source code itself because you need um
lots of people to do
that uh cyber security and citizen data
privacy uh software supply chain
exploits are increasingly being used by
Bad actors to successfully compromise
systems by inserting malicious code
through the supply chain users of the
software may be vul vulnerable and not
even know it commercial software
companies have direct control over their
supply chain so have the ability to
manage it by definition the development
of Open Source software exercises little
or no control over who inserts code and
what that code
is we learn about new vulnerabilities in
open source source software that is
installed in our environment on a weekly
basis and that's no exaggeration since
most of it is sourced from supported
entities
we are receiving and installing patches
versus coding the corrections ourselves
think labor cost and even that is a
resource challenge increasing our open-
source footprint would only exacerbate
this problem as an example all of the
website defacements that have occurred
on state websites around the country a
majority have been accomplished by
implementations the new Norm for rans
someware is that perpetrators extract
the data prior to ransoming it this
means that cyber security risks inherent
with open source also become citizen
data privacy
risks now it's ironic that I'm speaking
about this today because the the single
largest um exploit that we've had to
deal with um ever is log 4J you may have
seen it in the news um it may have
impacted our company in in Massachusetts
who does um payroll and and Personnel
processing that was taken down um we're
scrambling as I speak to patch systems
in the state um based on that open
source Library that's in many many
places in the state and around the
world risks to Federal funding streams
the state of New Hampshire is regularly
audited for compliance to standards
promulgated by the federal agencies we
deal with to maintain services and
funding streams to the state a small
percent percentage of Open Source
Products will meet those standards so in
general it's only appropriate to use
Open Source Products when the use case
is not dealing with regulated citizen
data and that's how we look at things
when we're evaluating
procurements capability and
appropriateness as with all states the
state of New Hampshire has hundreds of
different ways we interact with citizens
using
technology in the case where an open
source product meets the requirements of
the use case and is appropriately
compliant and or the use case does not
deal with regulated citizen data then
that product will likely be considered
as part of the procurement process great
example is our web content management
system when we went out to look we found
the best value a high highly supported
environment and we procured that open-
Source product and we're running it
today and implementing it on all new
websites in the executive branch
judicial branch uh and Secretary of
State's office in most cases there's no
requirements that concludes my testimony
thank you for
listening thank you director gulay are
there any questions from the committee
Shu thank you madam chair um hello um Mr
Gay um I I'm looking at the uh statute
that already
exists uh concerning your department and
I see that there are two uh Consulting
committees uh the legislative uh
oversite committee and there's a council
that's basically comprised of several
state department heads uh do they have
an active role in recommending to your
department what kinds of software you
should look at uh that assists them in
doing their job they do um you
particularly the information Technology
Council which um we um I think of as the
board of directors for it executive
branch it but we also uh I I asked that
um and introduced legislation in
previous sessions to add to that so we
have members from the uh uh judicial
branch um as well as the secretary
State's office as well to make sure we
have a broader you know you know a
broader input into that and and all
matters of strategy and cyber security
are open for consideration there and are
considered and particularly around you
know uh keeping the committee appris of
what our overall strategy is with
respect to Big treads in the industry
and you know open source actually is
trending you know particularly now with
the log 4J exploit it'll be interesting
to see what happens because software
companies that had been putting all
these libraries in their in their um
products to save money are now going oh
gee you know um now I have to they're
all out there scrambling and spending a
ton of money to make their customers
whole so whether that has a long-term
impact on the open source um Community I
don't know but I I would suspect that it
may and we'll be tracking that and and
making recommendations through the it
counil legislative oversight committee
hasn't really been called very often and
and I know there was a a study committee
that was done um I think right before
covid where we were looking at whether
whether that might actually be
eliminated as a committee and I think
that the thought was that they would
because the council was pretty there are
two State reps on the it Council as well
I'd like to see more State reps on there
I'd like to see four and that maybe some
future legislation we could add
that thank you br Senator
Schmidt thank you madam chairman uh so
good morning commissioner uh morning
the chair's already indicated this is
going to
subcommittee uh so would would you or
one of your
staff uh be available for the
subcommittee because uh I'm not on the
subcommittee and I'm grateful for that
uh
because all the stuff is basically you
if you were speaking Chinese I would not
understand substantially less and I
don't speak Chinese um so uh will you be
available for for the subcommittee
absolutely thank
you other qu other
questions
saitech Madam chairman this is out of
order but I'd like to ask it anyway our
town was hijacked was through ran
someware and it took weeks to recover
does the state have any is the state
aware what does the state do to prevent
the
ransomware from inflicting you know one
day we get on and there's nothing
screwing
blank um very good question um we're
doing a number of things right now um
one is I it was it's been you know it
seems like a long time we we actually
requested a grant of close to a half a
million dollars a Homeland Security
Grant um that was specifically targeted
at Municipal cyber security concerns and
that that whole Grant process slowed way
down during Co but it it restarted
recently and we did um accept and expend
that 475,000 that's addressed two two
areas for for communities one in in in
all communities are eligible one is to
develop uh to work with them do
Statewide
um um tabletop exercises so that
interested members of political
subdivisions can participate and from
that participation and we'd host it in
various locations around the state so
that people don't have to travel as far
as they would if you know it was
centralized and and secondly we would
from that we would develop a cyber
security um disruption template that um
political subdivisions can use which
really helps because it helps you
understand and get um get a knowledge of
what um can you know what you should be
doing and and how you'd react should
something happen um the second part of
that Grant is actually piloting some
tools with uh cyber uh with subdivisions
who have volunteered to do so to learn
you know how we could efficiently and
effectively Implement um and strengthen
the Cyber posture in um in our political
subdivisions another thing we're just
about to send in another Grant request
for a little over $100,000 in which we
would offer free cyber awareness
training for Municipal Employees around
not mandatory but free voluntary cyber
awareness training for Municipal
Employees that's a big deal because it's
when we see I I some of those I get to
dissect some of those um things that
happen in your communities and and uh
often times it's it's it's um you know
things that you know because of cyber
awareness training we've had mandatory
in the state for years now um a lot of
state employees wouldn't have done that
but a Municipal Employee might have done
it because they just didn't know they
shouldn't so that's another thing that's
going on there um and then uh finally um
with the infrastructure Bill uh the
the state of New Hampshire um stands to
be able to access 12.4 million for of
cyber grant funding that is Target 80%
of which is targeted at uh political
subdivisions State um you know cities
towns um and schools so we're now
looking at that that that's set up to be
a matching program so that I would you
know i' need a propriation you know
general fund appropriation matches so
that I could access that money and we're
still waiting for guidance from Treasury
and from from other entities inside the
uh federal government on how we access
that money but one thing to take away
here for any anybody that's um thinking
about budgeting is that is designed to
be a matching you know program with
matches and I can share with the
committee in or anybody information that
we have so far about what that looks
like um we operate a um kind of a a a
public private partnership right now
with um it's my it's the
doit and Homeland Security emergency
management and the National Guard state
New Hampshire uh National Guard as well
as primex who ensures all ensures 85% of
all our political subdivisions in all of
our saus um who's obviously very
interested because they have you know
when there's a cyber successful
ransomware attack or whatever they are
the ones that are covering that um also
Federal entities like the FBI and um and
and and other entities that um you know
like DHS sisa for example so so we're
doing a lot um not as much as I'd like
to but a
lot thank you other
questions representative roads thank you
madam
chairman thank you for taking my
question uh the our chairman asked the
sponsor about a fiscal note and as I'm
looking through I'm just seeing
funding um develop develop a funding
mechanism um estimated
appropriation all through here do you
even have a a rough
guesstimate the cost of implementing
something like this um well I was
surprised there was no fiscal note
attached to this but I have to say I
would have a really hard time attaching
cost to this but it wouldn't be small I
think it would take me between a year
and two years to figure out what it
would actually cost this is that's how
is you're
welcome repr Senator
Schmidt thank you m again Madam chair so
you mentioned towns and cities uh I'm
wondering uh did you leave out counties
intentionally or is are counties not
part of the process uh no I I I I should
that was an error of omission uh I
didn't uh counties are also party as
well I'm glad to hear that thank you and
we have County representation on the
information Technology Council as well
Mr other
questions all right thank you and I look
forward to your support of the
subcommittee thank
Hall
I would like to introduce myself I have
been a professional programmer and
president of computing industry for over
half a century I used to work for
digital Equipment Corporation along with
a bunch of other different companies
both proprietary and open source and
free software
systems I've also been educator teaching
at the University level and I started
the greater New Hampshire Linux users
group in
1995 we've talked a lot about money
today I would like to talk about total
cost of
ownership uh certain closed Source
companies proprietary companies talk
about total cost of ownership and in the
early days of free software yes the
total cost of ownership was higher
because of the lack of people who really
knew the software and knew how to to
work with it however those same
companies have recognized that in the
last 10 years the total cost of
ownership has actually been about the
same you trade off the cost of the
licenses that you pay for the software
for the cost of maintaining it and so
over a five-year period they've actually
produced studies to show that total cost
of ownership of free software is
actually about the
same however that's not what you should
care about you should really care about
the return on investment that you're
making where does the money that you
spend go to improving the software
environment and improving the lives of
your
constituents are you going to be sending
billions of dollars to Redmond
Washington and to keep them paid up with
their licenses or are you going to spend
that money paying local software
developers to help give you the support
and create the changes to the systems
that you
need another issue that has come up is
the concept of security and whether or
not free software is
secure well I happen to have worked for
companies like deck who made proprietary
software and I can tell you the same
things happen that a programmer creates
a piece of code there's a mistake in it
it goes out to a large group of people
large group of companies and it creates
a
trapo however the difference between
free software and proprietary software
is that once the issue is understood how
long does it take that company to create
that patch which can be then applied to
your closed Source software with open-
Source software typically the patch is
created very fast and it can be applied
to many different
systems uh and an example of this was
something called The Morris worm it took
deck three weeks to generate a patch to
Unix systems that were causing the
systems to crash the free software
Community had created that patch in
source code in three hours after they
understood the problem and distributed
it to the
people this is why PC Magazine for three
years in a row gave the award for best
support not to huip Packard or IBM or
deck but to the free software
community and if you want to talk about
mean time to fix which is the problem
that we're addressing you need to ask
yourself how long you going to wait for
the mean time to fix for Windows
XP which has been retired by Microsoft
for a number of years and yet there's
still an estimated 12 million systems
out there of people trying to use
Windows X XP and perhaps still attached
to the
internet and in case you say well that's
Windows XP that's a long time ago we
have to think about Windows 11 which is
not going to run on all of the hardware
which you have Microsoft has already
said that and their answer is well just
keep using Windows 10 and we'll support
that as long as the grass shall grow and
the water shall
flow uh I'd also like to talk about
education as a college professor I would
use proprietary software to teach the
students how to solve a problem that's
teaching them one
time but if I use free software they can
take a look at the soft at the source
code for the software and see how the
program solves the
problem they can also learn how to make
the software solve the problem better
for the end user and finally they can
actually work with the free software
Community to make that software better
which is gives them a leg up in the real
software people talk about the fact that
software producers and software authors
should be paid I agree I also think that
musicians should be paid but how much
money actually goes to the musicians who
create the music and how much goes to
the companies that that distribute it
and I think we all know that how many of
you know the leader of the Microsoft
development
team probably none of you how many of
you have seen the names of the authors
of that software distributed with
Microsoft software nobody because they
don't allow it on the other hand many
people have heard about lenus toural
it's the creator of the lyic system and
a lot of the software developers they
sign their names to
it and yes they are paid they're paid by
Red Hat they're paid by IBM you may have
heard of them they're paid by hulet
Packard they're paid by Apache they're
paid by lots of
people we heard about an unfortunate
problem in a piece of code which was
open source here's the difference
between open source and free
software with open source you get to use
the source code but you don't have to
give your changes out to the end
users this is a problem because
companies can utilize that open source
code in their closed Source proprietary
products and the end users don't have
that fix to fix that
problem only when that proprietary
company redistributes that patch that's
why free software is important not just
open
source people ask about if things
unreliable is open source unreliable
I've been using open source
exclusively exclusively since
1995 I don't use apple I don't use
Microsoft I do use Android from Google
which is based upon the Linux kernel
Android by the way which is creating
additional revenues for Hardware
companies that for some reason can't
license the Apple code from Apple itself
to put on their Hardware but they can
license
Android I would like to mention that we
so far in a lot of this bill we've
talked about free software but there's a
counterpart to this which is called open
hardware and also open culture also
known as creative comments this protects
the data that is paid for with public
money and keeps what can be Public
public that is also very important thing
to
do you're spending public money in this
and therefore the things that can be
used by the public should be used by the
public public maybe there are other
states who would also like to use free
software who also have many of the same
problems that you do and when that
problem is solved you can share that
problem amongst you therefore
multiplying the money which you
spent a lot of rfps requests for
proposals are written by people who want
to see a specific answer and they write
them with specific spe ific Clauses that
force people answering that into a
specific product that should not be done
the RFP should be open as
possible in the free software Community
today there are
400,000 different free software projects
in places like Source Forge and git
which itself started out as a free
software project and there's 2.6 million
developers working on it and most of
living you should collect data you talk
about collecting data many of the major
databases in use today are free software
projects databases like
postgress you know Mariah DB couch DB
other large datab bases to solve very
large problems or free software you
don't have to pay the license licensing
fee over and over and over again for
them I used to take students who had
never even touched a keyboard and in two
years trained them to be able to do
right compilers and operating
systems security is not something you do
overnight it's not something which is
solvable only by software you also have
to have the training in how to do
it we talk about how many people it
takes to run a state like New Hampshire
I really don't know but I can tell you
about one project in the early days of
Linux called Garden Grove
California where a programming staff of
three people using free software and a
technique known as three- tier client
server Computing wrote an ran an entire
Ci's government the police department
the fire department the tax collector
everything with with those three people
working in this
environment we talk about holes in
software from proprietary companies how
many of you have a dlink router in your
house I do or I did but dlink had a a
trapo in it for years that allowed
anybody on the dlink support Community
to go in and to find and to open up that
system and have control of it and the
only reason we found out about it was
because somebody reverse engineered the
object code from dlink so please do not
tell me that proprietary companies know
what their programmers are doing it
way do not teach products to your
students teach principles principles of
security princi principles of database
principles of networking do not teach
Cisco networking do not teach Microsoft
Office do not teach that if you're going
to teach something teach how to use an
office product to run your business
better and then you can use any office
product and for the people to say to me
we have to teach these products because
that's what people are using in the real
world I say to you you're teaching
students who can do brain surger y
create Bridges build buildings they're
smart enough to do that but they're
somehow they're too stupid to be able to
pick up a book on Microsoft Office and
learn how to use it in a single
day you can't have it both ways they're
either smart or they're
stupid and
so I don't think that this bill is
perfect very little is I think that a
lot could be done by forming that
committee and working forward to
creating a basis where New Hampshire
could be looked at
as a element as a central point for the
training of free
software in the whole United
States and we could actually make money
off of
it from my viewpoint there's only two
things that New Hampshire makes maple
syrup and
software and I don't know about you but
I'm tired of sending a Redmond
Washington to Silicon Valley for
software that our people could make and
there's only so much maple syrup that
Bill Gates can
drink with that thank you very much for
listening if you have any questions I'll
them are there any questions not seeing
any thank you Mr Hall and I would be
happy to work with your committee if you
wanted me to represent movich will be
scheduling it yes repres representative
Schmidt he just answered my question
thank
Wade members could you shut your mics
on okay so it's oh it's red weird Red's
on okay um so yeah I'm Christopher Wade
uh I'm a resident of keen New Hampshire
um I am also a CEO of a technology
company that deals with free software
and spe specifically uh with Hardware um
but uh I have a lot of experience in
this basically and supporting uh
especially uh in the past uh past uh
more more in the past but um recent past
but um companies doing migrations to
free software um and I I can say that it
is actually cheaper to migrate to free
software the overall costs anyway even
if there is an investment cost um so
it's uh I I was a little concerned about
some of the testimony here today because
it was just inaccurate and misleading
and manipulative um but one of one of
the things I actually have a concern
about this bill is that these it people
um they know how to work around a lot of
these sorts of bills and that they will
put in specific feature requests that
they know only one particular
application can fill um but one of the
benefits of free software is you can
actually add functionality uh yourself
if you want to um so it kind of is it's
very disingenous to say well we have to
go with this particular application uh
proprietary application if you can also
add that same feature to a free software
application and then avoid uh those
licensing costs now that doesn't mean
that the free software is uh
automatically um going to be the uh you
know solution that that's that's uh that
you're going to want like sometimes
you're you're just going to want to go a
certain route um uh and and because over
the long call it's going to be the best
route right so let me uh bring up let me
just here go here want to say some more
stuff here um so what one of the other
things I want to point out is that free
software really doesn't have anything to
do with the costs um you want to invest
in free software development rather than
funding spending money or sending money
to Washington DC we've already got
companies it we had a really solid
technology
industry 20 plus years ago in New
Hampshire and we lost out because we
didn't take the right steps and this is
an opportunity to fix and correct those
things New Hampshire is still a very uh
good place to do software development
technology um and we've actually been
track attracting over the last decad or
so uh a lot of small companies back to
New Hampshire and most of them are
dealing with free software development
so it's something that you should
consider as well because it will end up
with money going into the pockets of of
our citizens as opposed to you know
citizens over in
Washington all right uh let's
see all right so I think the major thing
though honestly about this bill is it
actually improves the security situation
um so what people don't understand is
that Microsoft uses free software right
like like Microsoft actually moved to
using Linux as part of its system and
Linux is free software right so because
of the security uh implications and the
the dangers of proprietary I don't know
if people remember but anybody who's
using Windows you know a couple decade
like 20 years ago viruses you know
constant virus does Linux ly doesn't
even have antivirus software for it
because it actually fixes the bugs as
opposed to Windows where you have to
wait for bug fixes from Microsoft that
never get fixed and then you need
antivirus software as a result but of
course the antivirus software doesn't
even work but they don't they don't
usually tell you that it's just kind of
your only option um so one of the things
else I want to point out is too is that
uh I thought the it was pretty ingenious
to bring up the uh vulnerability with
Java here recently
um that sort of vulnerability it it's
going to happen in any software
regardless of whether the sources are
available for it or not um they actually
happen way more frequently in the
proprietary software and unfortunately
we're unable to fix those bugs um we are
relying on other companies most of the
time those bugs don't get fixed now I
thought it was interesting uh that John
here brought up the router situation
because that's one of the things I am
actually an expert in did you know that
almost all routers on the market today
are full of holes and problems uh
there's like one in 10 that you can get
that actually isn't problematic so and
the reason and the funny thing about
this is most of those are based on free
software but the holes are not in the
free software they're in the proprietary
components that you're relying on that
run on top generally and in order to fix
them you actually have to revert to a
completely free system so um because the
manufacturers themselves don't produce
they don't put out the fixes the fixes
exist but they only exist in the free
versions now if the company actually
support their product properly which
proprietary software developers
generally don't then those those bugs
those problems those exploits wouldn't
be exploitable um so this is this is one
of these problems with proprietary
software companies if if the company
that you are buying the software from
doesn't fix the problem you can't fix it
so um one of the other things I I want
to point out is proprietary software
often hinders support so and it does it
in many many different ways um in one
way if it's like a piece of Hardware say
you bought a printer yesterday and you
buy a new computer today with a new
operating system if it's a proprietary
operating system you can't use that old
the printer you bought six months ago
with the new operating system with Linux
and free software you can and it's not
the support's not going to just
disappear so there's all sorts of costs
that you will find uh that don't exist
in the free software World As you move
away that never get taken into account
uh when you're do when you're running
the numbers and um I think that's
something that's important to to mention
so it's not that there's no cost again
it's not free software is not about the
price has nothing to do with the price
it has it has more to do with the
security and the control over uh the
software you're running another issue is
old uh old file formats if you are using
an old uh like for example word I think
it was word perfect word perfect for a
long time was the standard but try
opening a Word Perfect document today
good luck you won't be able to um and
that's because it's a proprietary format
create with a proprietary program but if
you were using a free software format
right free software program you wouldn't
have these problems and this is a big
problem when you're talking about
looking at archival uh Records so
definitely um this is this is an
important bill I don't think it's like
the perfect bill but it's certainly
adequate it's certainly going to address
have so I think one of the important
things to bring up are the migration
costs migration costs are actually
fairly small in the scheme of things um
there there is a migration cost but what
people have to remember is there's
always a migration cost from one version
to the next when you're running Windows
7 and you go to upgrade to Windows
8 that was a particularly good example
because the user interface changed
drastically that had
significant uh migration costs in user
training okay um I at that at that point
in time when that was going on I
remember I was supporting both windows
users and I was supporting Linux users
when we moov people to Linux mint I
didn't have any training to do I didn't
have to teach them anything they just
picked it up on their own because you
didn't have those drastic changes but
with Windows you did so it it really
depends on like what versions uh of the
software people are moving from to
determine how expensive it actually is
but the training costs actually aren't
necessarily that great because often
times the user interfaces are very
similar between Windows and Linux or
free and non-f free software um now
there are sometimes differences like
apple is pretty different using
interface than than uh windows but
between say Linux which is usually what
people think about when they talk about
free software um it's actually
frequently almost identical so there's
not this huge uh learning or teaching or
educational cost that is being uh
disingenuously uh
suggested um and like I said I have
experience with this so I know um I deal
with some of the largest companies in
the world actually in supporting uh
mostly these at these days with Hardware
but basically um I'm the leading expert
basically in the world on this so all
right
um so most of the cyber security risks
are actually impacting proprietary
software um the control chains uh
Microsoft as we were saying before
Microsoft and other proprietary software
companies actually use free software so
any argument that you have like that
free software somehow less secure well
you're already using it um it's not and
the reason it's not is because there's
I'll give you an example Debian is a
version of Linux and Debian in order to
submit in order to get your your source
code into Debian you have to do what's
called submitting a patch right and a
patch basically changes the software but
not anybody can submit a patch not
anybody can contribute to deban you you
can submit a patch and Debian will
accept or deny your patch and over time
as you become trusted uh just like maybe
an employee would at a company um you
will then be given more and more ability
to submit patches maybe without
additional review that doesn't mean
there's nobody reviewing it there is but
it's it's not uh it's not just
automatically occurring excuse me it it
seems that you're getting very much into
the Weeds on how free software operates
could you stick to what's relevant to
bill
[Music]
um I think we're talking about the heart
mistaken um okay uh so the other thing
is propri software can't be audited free
software can be audited that's another
thing whenever you start talking about
SEC especially security and security is
the heart of this bill um you
are you are you're unable to H not
proprietary software um so there's no
way to know whether or not it's secure
or not when you talk about encryption
encryption this is usually where it
comes up with if you don't have the
source code there's there's no point in
talking about security there's no way to
tell I mean you might be able to exploit
it but you're not going to be able to do
a proper
audit all right one last thing um so
there was an exploit here recently or
I'm sorry there they they were talking
about an exploit that happened with some
of our municipalities here and that had
to do with Bitcoin basically and I want
to point out that that's actually a
social engineering problem not a problem
with the security of the software it
wasn't had nothing to do with
proprietary software or free software
cyber security training is also I think
misleading way to phrase things because
it again it doesn't have to do with
technology at all it has to do with
people being social engineered it's
fraud and people need to be aware
whether somebody's calling you on the
phone trying to get you to you know wire
money or they're trying to get you to
buy Bitcoin on the Internet it's a
social and Engineering problem not a
chech
thank you I'm I'm watching a brawl here
between experts and I don't know whom to
believe uh I you may have your own actx
to grind as Oppo meaning you don't like
Windows maybe I don't either but I'm
wondering whether there's some
evangelism going on here but let I just
want to make a remark for you uh you use
what's ringing in my ears are misleading
and um deceptive or something like that
when you started your testimony and the
man the gentleman the commissioner is
we've known him a long time I don't
think that those words fit i' please be
careful because you've got you probably
have some good things to say i' like to
buy your router when it comes out Mr
Hardware but U I'm not here to sell you
anything I just caution you that that
just wasn't a welcome thing to hear no I
think people should be aware that
sometimes people have their own
interests
and I we're well aware of people
presenting their own interests yeah it's
coffin Madam chair if I could just
request that when people come up to
testify that they a identify themselves
if they have uh a an unusual ual name
perhaps they could spell their name so
that we can get that information done
correctly thank you thank you
representative Schmidt in this case Mr
coffin's name is spelled exactly as you
would think yep like the thing they bury
you in when you die that's my last name
um uh good morning
everyone I'll start out by uh explaining
who I am I've been using uh free and
open sauce software since uh
1996 and I'm a computer security
researcher um so I deal with
everything uh let's see let's let's
start um if we look at last
year um most of the
vulnerabilities that were exploited in
the wild and let me clarify what that
means when something is exploited in the
wild it's something that uh nobody knows
about and people are exploiting it so
it's a zero day vulnerability it hasn't
been fixed yet most of them are with
um for
example last year the Microsoft Mail
Server uh had like a major
vulnerability and the fix was the FBI
hacked into all of them and fixed it for
you because that's part of the Microsoft
guarantee um you wouldn't get that with
free and open source software because it
fixed uh let's see I'm not really the
best at this my notes are kind of
scattered
uh if we look at if we look at the
90s um I don't know if anybody remembers
uh Microsoft and Carta it was an
encyclopedia
program and in the 90s as somebody told
you oh there's going to be this you know
online encyclopedia and anybody can
contribute to it nobody would believe
you but we're all using that right now
it's called Wikipedia that's a free and
open source
system um I don't know about you I
haven't seen a Microsoft and carded dis
for a very long
time uh let's
see another thing in the proprietary
software World um antiviruses and
viruses were created by the same company
if that's not a great business model uh
we don't see this in the free software
and open source software
World um let's see uh I think Hardware
obsolescence was mentioned so so in the
free and soft free and open- Source
software
world we can continue to use the same
hardware for decades if we really want
as long as it doesn't fail us
unfortunately with Microsoft Windows
every time they come out with a newer
release certain Hardware isn't able to
be used anymore and that includes
printers computers etc uh so a lot of
that ends up going to landfills
um where we could actually just not have
to buy new systems there's a
considerable cost to buying a new
computer every couple of years I think
everybody can agree with
that uh let's
see uh somebody else had already
mentioned uh social engineering it is
the weakest
link um you can have the highest
Security in the world and you can break
into a company because you convince
somebody that you are somebody you're
difficult um and then I guess for my my
last point I just kind of wanted to
bring something in perspective so
uh there was a computer security
conference that happened at the end of
December uh one of the talks um this
woman she uh had talked about her
profession uh her profession is she's a
tech dominatrix what that means yeah
yeah I that's getting way off topic if
you don't mind well I that's fair that
you can say that but can you let me
finish
please so anyway I'm not going to talk
I'm going to just briefly mention about
this person or Tech Dominator job is to
hack into people's computers with the
permission take over the system and lock
them out and apparently that's part of
the game I guess anyway during her
question and answer session none of her
customers are running free and open
source software they're all running
proprietary software they're all running
Microsoft Windows they're all running
Apple like these
are I don't know if anybody's actually
tried breaking into a computer
professionally but the proprietary stuff
is usually a lot easier to do that with
with because the holes have not been
fixed and that's my last
comment thank you very much are there
committee okay not seeing any thank you
for your testimony thank
you is there anyone else who wishes to
1273 okay seeing none I will close the
public hearing
1581 and call
Representative bery you're going to
introduce
you so that was a lot of testimony on
the previous bill um some of it applies
to this one this is a much smaller bill
um I will read my testimony it's short
it's 3 quarters of a page but I think it
will answer some questions and maybe
summarize a lot of what was said
previously um so chairwoman McGuire
members of the Edna committee thank you
for the opportunity to introduce HB 1581
relative to the use of Open Source
software by state
agency uh this bill aims to reinstate
the requirement for state agencies to
consider open source when acquiring
software so what does it mean for
software to be open source open source
software is analogous to a Vehicle
Manufacturer providing repair manuals
and schematics for the inner workings of
their vehicle such information allows
the owner of the vehicle to make any
repairs or modifications as necessary
but even more importantly it allows them
to shop around for a mechanic knowing
that the mechanic will have the
information they need to make the repair
Clos Source software or proprietary
software on the on the other hand is
analogous to a Vehicle Manufacturer who
does not provide wide repair manuals and
instead only allows you to bring the
vehicle uh to their own repair
shop this kind of vendor lock in with
proprietary software can lead to higher
prices as the vendor no longer needs to
compete limited interoperability with
other software especially with a
competitor's product and expensive or
unavailable
customization in 2012 considering the
same issues with proprietary software
the legislature passed this exact bill
um h B 418 adding that a adding a
requirement that agencies consider open
source when it when it can be a coste
effective alternative unfortunately six
years later an Omnibus it restructuring
Bill HB 1622 relative to organization of
the Department of Information Technology
removed this requirement the committee
report at the time also stated nothing
about this change and exclusively
focused on the Personnel hierarchy of
the new it
Department open source gives our
government more agency to manage its
software saves tax dollars over the long
run and maximizes transparency and
access to
government uh the federal government
also provides support to agencies
considering open source software via uh
code.gs on this bipartisan legislation
thank you for your consideration and
questions
representative
Schmidt is this going to the same
you representative fellows thank you
madam chair um representative in in this
bill you've essentially replaced
technology with
software so I'm wondering is it really
your intent to remove from
um statute that the it depart Department
should be used for consultation and to
help with decisions
about Hardware about computers
networking equipment
things so to answer your question um the
goal of my bill was just to bring it
back to the way it was before 2018
and in in that language they had um
software so and if you were to change it
to technology to include Hardware you're
now going Beyond open source software
you're not going into open Hardware
which is also a valid thing but is a lot
less common there's not a lot of open-
Source Hardware out in the world um so
the reason for that is because if we are
going to uh require the government to at
least consider open- Source software
then the language has to be software um
and and that's why it's it's software as
technology saying none thank you
Gallagher
so hi again um yeah it's Eric Gallagher
uh here to testify to rep uh the
representatives um own bill on open
source software um
so he and I came up with the ideas for
our bill those completely independently
from one another um yeah I I didn't um
hear about his
until it was already filed so I think
the fact that we've
got people in both parties thinking
about
this issue independently
shows that there's a wide range of
support for it um so I I essentially see
uh his bill
as a milder version of my own bill it
only addresses the procurement part
um and um only talks about a
consideration rather than making a
requirement
um so my bill had its own procurement
portion in it um so I'm not exactly
sure how the two of our bills would
interact if both of them packed but
passed but I am perfectly willing to rip
the procurement section out of my own
bill and replace it with um
representative Beres if that's what's
necessary to harmonize the two of them
um so
and yeah that's if both of them pass if
if only one of them can pass I mean I
I'd prefer it would be mine but if it
can't be mine then it would be good if
thank you we'll consider that in the
subcommittee whether either or both of
these should pass in what form
okay so yeah um I I support his
too and I'll take any
questions thank you are there
questions seeing n thank you very much
now my name is Jeffrey peard I was born
and raised in New Hampshire graduated
from gtown high school and from UNH with
a degree in math I also own and operate
a small business in New Hampshire I've
been a software engineer professionally
for about the last 10 years and during
my time in that field I've had to make a
lot of decisions about what software
products to use for various projects in
my experience with very few exceptions
open- Source Solutions work better they
are cheaper and easier to find support
for and to maintain for these reasons I
think it would benefit our government to
use more open-source software and I
support with this
Bill thank you very much are there any
committee thank you for your
testimony
yes
yes okay we'll we'll let you know when
it's
Hall
I promise to be
brief I would support this bill except
for one thing it states open source
software instead of free software and I
want to make very very clear why this is
important open-source software is good
for the companies it's good for the
developers because it brings together
software that's written by many people
that can help them create a product but
there is no requirement in the licensing
of that software to pass on their
changes to the end
user and you folks are the end user you
are and so you you know if there is
open-source software that's on your
systems you're not guaranteed to have
the changes that the developer made to
them if that developer goes out of
business then you can't fix it if that
developer loses interest in that uh
video graphics card or they lose
interest in the printer mechanism that
you have you can't fix it and you can't
hire anybody to fix it because they
don't know how to fix it so free
software is very important from a
longevity
standpoint and that's what you need to
remember also open Hardware is very
important because without the hardware
being specifi ified in an open fashion
with all of the hardware intricacies
exposed free software people cannot give
it the type of support that you would
like to have and there are companies who
produce open Hardware we should help
them we should encourage them to do that
so that your printers your modems your
everything can survive long into the
future because somebody has a source
code for that other than the developer
themselves and if you say to yourselves
this is why we buy our hardware and
software from large companies that will
never go out of business then I have
only one word to say to you
deck or Kodak or Enron or any one of the
other large companies that went out of
business so fast it made your head spin
questions I don't see any thank you for
your testimony Mr Hall is there anyone
1581 okay I don't see anyone so I'm
closing the
hearing
1:15 Madam chair may we know which of
your subcommittees these bills are going
me
e
yeah
being 1:15 by at least 1:00 uh open the
hearing on House Bill 12113 and calling
representative
Reed thank you madam chair and thank you
uh honorable members of the committee
you're welcoming me into your committee
today and will be my first testimony of
the year so thank you um I hope you can
hear me okay uh I'm wearing this mask
the n95 mask only because I was told by
the speaker's office because I was
identified as one of the contacts and
and so I'm taking the necessary
precautions but I'm my rapid was
negative and I should be fine so anyway
uh hb1
1213 uh the meat of this bill is
essentially establishing uh election day
as a state holiday now I want to give
you a little bit of history on this bill
this is the third time I have introduced
uh a bill on in this vein the first time
to terms ago uh it was interesting it uh
very narrowly failed in committee but on
a bipartisan vote last year or last term
I should say um it passed out of
committee but there was uh confusion
about and I will get into the confusion
in a second about how to make a day a
holiday and um so it was amended out of
the committee to remove the actual
holiday piece for election day and
defining what that does and it only left
the last piece of the bill if you look
at um the bottom of the language that
says that employers regular employers
simply will give up to three hours
unpaid time off during polling hours to
employees should the employees request
time to go vote um that's what came out
of the house however this was 2020 and
the Senate tabled hundreds of bills
including this so here we go again now
the confusion from what I understand um
in that iteration in this committee was
basically and it took me several months
of contacting multiple departments to
ask them so what makes a holiday a
holiday uh in this state because as you
can see in the existing RSA here we have
a list of state holidays um we have
Washington's birthday and Memorial Day
July 4th but there's no definition for
what we do on a state holiday it's just
this is a state holiday now every day in
that list we shut down we except for
essential Services obviously we simply
shut most normal State uh offices on
those days with the exception of
election day so it kind of became this
weird Little Orphan holiday that we we
acknowledge it's a state holiday but we
don't really do anything to acknowledge
that it's a state holiday unlike all of
the other days in that list um Columbus
Day is kind of a weird one for most for
the most part we do shut down but there
may be local governments that choose not
to and and I can get in more into that
later um so what I did in this bill is
essentially the second paragraph I added
a definition for what a state holiday is
and in that wording I simply described
what we already do and essentially it is
we shut down State offices that are not
essential and each government
governmental unit can decide what is
essential for them and what is not um so
I still in this language allow the
flexibility for every governmental unit
whether it's Municipal County or what
have you to decide and have the leeway
to say we actually would like these
offices open on these days so I'm not
effectively really changing anything
because every unit still has the
potential to decide which offices stay
open for themselves but what I am doing
is giving a definition to a list that we
already have so that we have um
continuity across all these the other
piece that I'm doing is in addition to
the general election day I am adding the
day of the primary State primary
election so um the reason I'm doing that
is because primaries are extremely
important to our democracy and if I I
just need to pause right here to uh
Define the word democracy as you all
know it's democracy the power to the
people or rule by the people more
specifically last time I gave um
introduced this bill last term I was
asked by a member well don't we have a
republic not a democracy as it happens I
teach American government at the college
level and I just wanted to put out in
case any of you were wondering the same
thing what the definition is a republic
is one of two types of democracy
Republic specifically is a
representative democracy there are two
kinds there's direct democracy where
everybody votes on everything and
representative where we elect people to
represent us so we are a republic which
is a type of democracy so when I say
democracy please understand that that is
what I mean but I digress the point is
is that primaries are extremely
important to our democracy or Republic
because it is where we select the people
that we have to choose from in the
general um Boss Tweed who um is is kind
of Infamous as a a politician from the
1800s in the tamy hall political machine
uh of of dubious uh ethical uh traits he
famously said I don't care who gets to
vote as long as I do the
nominating so the and it's true because
the general public only has so much say
if the only access they have is during a
general election so um it may be that
they don't have any really meaningful
choice so that's why I added
primary um in general though I want to
speak very briefly about philosophically
why we should have election day as a
holiday the obvious one is obviously it
helps people to be able to vote New
Hampshire has the second highest of all
states voter turnout which is fantastic
Until you realize that our overall
turnout in this country is quite low
compared to other
democracies um the United States
territory of Puerto Rico however not a
state uh has 90 4% turnout I believe if
I recall correctly very high rate of
turnout interestingly they have election
day off and not only do they have
election day off but they actually
celebrate it like much like we do the
4th of July they have what they call
caravanas these parades where they
celebrate the concept of democracy and
that's really more to the point of why
yes it helps people to come vote but I
really think we should celebrate the
idea that we have a democracy and can
participate in it uh and and just as a
footnote uh Puerto Ricans when they move
to the mainland their voter turnout
drops to the 60% level much like the
rest of this country so having that
culture that celebrates a day where we
practice democracy and having that day
off really does influence voter turnout
now
in terms of holidays and what holidays
mean to us and how that ties back to
election day I'd like to you to ask
yourselves the days that we have off
especially when it has to do with the
our our national identity things like
the 4th of July where we celebrate our
independence Memorial Day veterans day
the President's Day all these days are
days to celebrate people who have stood
for fought and died for our democracy
but the one day sorry the one day we
actually do the democracy that they
fought and died for we don't have that
day off I contend I I I propose to you
to ask yourself if we had the presidents
Washington and Lincoln here whose
birthday we celebrate and take off would
they say yes please celebrate my
birthday with a state holiday or would
they say please take the day off to
engage in the Democracy that I spent my
life protecting if we had Martin Luther
King here whose birthday we recognize
with a state holiday would he say yes
celebrate my personal birthday or would
he say no I would rather you take a day
off and celebrate the fact that you have
a democracy and that you can engage with
it um so I Envision a day where we all
As Americans not only look forward to it
much like we look forward to today's off
on the calendar we know we're going to
have it off it's in our Consciousness
that we're going to have a day off from
work but
also that we literally will have
barbecues and fireworks and mock
elections and debates and really engage
in that civil Civic engagement that we
all talk about we should have more
of I honestly think that of all the
things we can do to help save our
democracy our Republic this is the
lowest hanging fruit
this is the easiest thing that we can do
now in terms of implementation and cost
and I'll um this will be brief there is
a fiscal note that's
indeterminate the idea is that there are
um employees that would have a day off
although they're getting paid for the
day there's an estimate in the note
about how much that would cost across
the state that number is for all the
counties of course the state doesn't pay
for the counties directly so so um that
number is kind of off however it's not
an actual cost in terms of increased
cost what that is is reduced um I guess
projected reduced productivity because
you're you're not increasing those
people's pay any You're simply giving
them a day off of work um and I would
say that the day that they're having off
of work because of this election day a
day where most of the employees come in
late leave early or take a lunch in
order to go vote is already not a very
productive day um so it's it's not
really a cost and sense of having to
spend more money you do end up saving a
little bit of money uh from in the sense
of overhead additional electricity if
you shut down offices um custodians
things like that so you end up saving
money you end up losing a little
productivity but overall what we're
talking about the effect is an extra
snow day a year on average I think our
democracy our Republic is worth an extra
snow day on average and I guess with
that I will happily take
questions thank you representative
leus thank you madam chair um I have a
question on uh lines 20
21 in your opening remarks you said that
uh for the uh private employers that
they would be giving the time off unpaid
but this doesn't say that it doesn't
make it clear one way or the other um so
I was curious why you thought it would
be
unpaid um that was the clear intention I
I I actually literally told the lawyer
in OS that would be unpaid um and I
think that the lawyer's interpretation
here was because it doesn't mandate pay
that obviously the employer has the
option and of course employers would
normally not choose to offer pay but if
they wanted to they could um but I if if
it helps this committee at all feel
comfortable um I would be happy to ask
for a friendly amendment to to make that
clearer but I think by saying unpaid
specifically it would somehow limit the
employer to force like if they they
wouldn't be allowed to offer paid
vacation okay uh followup if I may
actually it's sort of a separate
question and that's the LA the sentence
before that nothing in the section shall
uh prevent the designation of an
alternative holiday or leave schedule it
goes on
um I when I read it initially I wasn't I
kind of could guess what it meant but I
wasn't entirely sure and we got a letter
from the community college system in New
Hampshire
expressing um concern that at least to
them it was unclear what that meant
their concern was uh you know that their
days off were part of their collective
bargaining uh thing
so alter alternative holiday or whatever
I'm not quite sure what the intent was
right and this again is was not
something that I request of the lawyer
but the lawyer's way of saying this does
not impact any collective bargaining
agreements so obviously days off are
frequently though not always um for
employees if they are in a union they
will bargain for certain days off and
what this is saying is although this is
a state holiday and we're practicing
this like we do all of our other state
holidays if the collective bargaining
agreement in a particular area has
something else going on where they would
rather have this day off and that day or
what have you then that's fine this
Bailey is there really any point to
selecting an alternative holiday for
election day oh so not uh so not
alternative holiday for election day in
terms of you know allowing those
employees to go vote but the idea is if
someone say uh if we have an election
day that happens to happen during a
blizzard and people have to be out from
do to plow the roads that those people
would get another day off as a as a
could I shouldn't say would could get
another day off if that's in their
agreement um like we would do any
holiday that they're entitled to a
agreement thank you Pearson thank you
madam
chair
so line
20 all other employees employers excuse
me shall when practical allow up to
three hours away that's a ceiling not a
minimum correct okay so what prevents an
employer
from you know the letter of the law here
saying okay fine I'm going to allow my
employees 10 minutes I don't think
that's how that's interpreted um I can
certainly ask that question of the
lawyers and Os to see but I think the
way that this would legally be
interpreted is that the employer must
allow up to 3 hours if the employee the
in other words the employee can take up
to three hours to go vote but cannot
take more than three hours if it only
takes the employee 10 minutes to go vote
they can come back to work immediately
um but if the employee needs to drive to
another town what have you wait in line
they can take up to 3 hours and the
employer has to honor
that if there is a wording that is
improved and I certainly am happy to
talk to OS about this um to make that
clearer then I'm happy to to work on
you other
questions okay I don't see any thank you
very much representative Reed thank you
madam chairman I don't also don't see
anybody else who wishes to testify so in
that case I'm going to close the
[Music]
and
e
thank you
all um opening the public hearing on
House Bill 1037 and I call
Representative
Horgan thank you very much Madam shair
I'm representing Timothy Horgan I
represents straford County district 6
the towns of Durham and Madbury and I'm
here to introduce HB 137 and I I have
filled out a pink card and I do some
written testimony which I haven't handed
around the table yet but I'll do so
after I'm finished I so it's basically
well actually this bill it's basically a
oneline bill although this on line is
also included in a longer and probably
somewhat more controversial bill which
has not even been scheduled yet but but
um you're certainly uh but certain there
some value in Breaking this out as two
separate bills because U this has uh and
the title is relative to the governor's
Duty during a state of emergency and
it's um it modifies some language that
was placed in there the Budget Trailer
bill and I forget what the number of the
bill which then preceded the section of
the Budget Trailer bill but it um so it
tightens and the uh it tightens up the
language in RSA
21- P 43a which is a paragraph added RSA
21- P by the 2021 Budget Trailer bill
it's a lot of
21s RSA 21 p34 through p48 collectively
make up a subdivision titled Homeland
Security and Emergency Management which
was at added in the spring of 2002 in
response to the events of September 11th
2001 and um so it basically 43a
currently States um I think it just took
effect a few days ago we passed it last
year the governor shall provide a list
of all expenditures pursuant to the
subdivision under a state of emergency
to the executive Council for
informational purposes only within 30
days of the expenditure in order to
ensure transparency um so what my
proposal is to take out the Apparently
unnecessary phrases quote for
informational purposes only so I'm not
sure sure what other reason they would
be providing um that information so it
takes out for informational purposes
only and also in order to ensure
transparency so if this bill were to
become law Precision would simply State
the governor shall provide a list of all
expenditures pursuant to the subdivision
under a state of emergency to the
executive Council within 30 days
expenditure
period um I will admit that these two
phrases they seem meaningless they're
definitely unnecessary they also seem
meaningless since all expenditures must
already be reported in a timely fashion
um even when there is no
emergency but I think there's still some
value in uh deleting them and cleaning
up the language be just revent a
situation where some future Governor
during a future emergency ascribe some
certain meaning to these phrases and
then use as a pretext for uh not
reporting and or not listing certain
expenditures so that's uh that's
1037 that's my right there so I'd be
happy to answer any questions if there
are
any all right thank you very much are
there questions representative Shu and
then
Pearson thank you madam chair um
representative haran I can understand uh
removing the phrase for informational
purposes only um why did you choose to
delete the phrase in order to ensure
transparency because that's basically
what it does yes that's U that's fair
enough so every everything that's
reported uh to the executive council is
to ensure transparency and they Pro
there is a the transparency website
where I think all the expenditures would
be recorded anyway but um I thought that
was also unne that's yeah well I mean I
think it's uh doesn't change the meaning
of it one way or another I just figured
it yep uh but um so I didn't think that
I thought that was Superfluous too just
like the informational purposes only
thing about I mean it's the committee's
build they're certainly welcome to
Tinker with it all they want
so thank you representative
Pearson my Democratic colleague covered
that perfectly yes okay that's okay are
there any other questions that
representative
fellows thank you so um my question
question is is is it being is the
information I have two questions one is
is is the information being presented to
GNC well not now because we're past the
emergency order but was that
happening well um
before
and
um the other part of my question is are
they ex why why is it not being reported
so everybody in the public knows also um
and I don't necessarily know all the ins
and outs of this but my recollection was
the governor actually did bypass the
executive Council and the joint fiscal
committee so he sort of decreed that you
know any of the funding or other you
know other things that came down as part
of the state of emergency were were
separate from the routine business of
the state I mean although far as I can
tell the expend all the money the
governor spent or the executive branch
spend is was uh reported in a timely
fashion like non-emergency related
expenditures as far as I can far as I
can tell but I'm I may not there may be
others have a more detailed answer than
that
but are there any other questions from
the
committee all right I don't see any so
thank you very much representative Oran
oh thank you is there anyone else who
10:37 don't not seeing any I'm going to
hearing
e
I
welcome back committee I'm uh opening
the hearing on house Bill 10002 and I
call Representative Littlefield who will
it
hello introduce yourself first hello
everybody I'm representative Littlefield
from
lonia and I'm here representing uh
representative
Traer good afternoon Madam chair and
members of the Edna committee I want to
thank you all for your time and
consideration on this
bill I am representative Littlefield a
co-sponsor on this bill the prime
sponsor representative Traer was unable
to attend this hearing and has asked me
to represented to the
committee this bill was to establish a
committee to study the feasibility of
state-owned take-home vehicles and the
usage of
them however it was brought to our
attention in the past few days a study
on this issue had been performed within
the past couple of years which concluded
no real Financial impact on
taxpayers so I am respectfully
requesting this this committee to itl
the bill whereby the prime sponsor and I
do not feel another study needs to be
performed at this time since one was
completed so recently again thank you
consideration thank you representative
Littlefield are there any
questions no all right thank you for
coming and telling us in person and uh
good
day is there anyone else who wishes to
bill2 oh excuse me rep Brian did you
have a question yeah I I'm very sorry no
excuse me I think I was a little bit out
of turn I did not have a question but
I'll wait uh I was going to make the
recommendation and to uh get into an
executive session on
you since there is there is there any
anyone who wishes to
testify okay in that case I'll close the
public hearing on house
bill2 representative O'Brien suggests we
go into executive session and do you
have a motion representative O'Brien
thank you madam chair uh my motion will
be to uh itl House Bill
1,2 I will second that okay and seconded
by Pearson do you wish to speak to your
motion uh as we just seen we heard from
the prime sponsor they said a previous
study was done and uh there's no actual
need at this particular time for this
Bill thank you madam chair okay bman
Pearson do you wish to say add anything
uh just one thing um having had a
discussion with with someone last week
and reference This Not only was the was
the study done prior but the study found
there was really no impropriety going on
and no problems either so it's not that
it it doesn't need to be looked at we
actually don't even have a problem so so
yeah I'd like to say there was a
previous study more like 10 years ago
that I was working on and we just
determined that the most important thing
was to clarify what the rules were so
everybody knew what they were and that
was done and uh and as you say followup
says there's no problem so
I'm does anyone else wish to
comment
question okay seeing none in that case
the motion is inexpedient to legislate
by representative O'Brien and the clerk
microphone
say let me ask can can we be heard for
the vote from the uh microphones that
pick up the room I mean it's just the I
no yes this will be a nice practice
we'll learn how to turn the mics on
before we speak and turn them off when
we stop
speaking in incidentally I found out
that the
remote signin sheets are similar to blue
sheets and they will be provided with
the blue sheets in the folders for
executive sessions except for this
one I I don't think I have the dexterity
to call the role and
be you leave your could be up to three I
think this is very this is very exciting
okay the clerk votes yes representative
Pearson
yes representative yakovich yes
representative leus yes by the way
that's how he pronounces his name thank
you I've tried to get the speaker to
change how he pronounces it it's a short
e algro a representative algro yes
represent representative
Bailey yes okay repres representative
Lara yes rep representative Santo
naso yes representative goalie yes
representative sh yes representative
Schmidt yes representative Marsh yes
representative fellows yes
representative groa yes representative
O'Brien
yes and the
chair
consent and without objection it'll go
on
consent representative of O'Brien you
could give me a blurb at your earliest
convenience
[Laughter]
W Madam
chair yes representative sh yes uh while
we are technically in executive session
mode
uh I would move that we um work on House
Bill
pass okay I will uh accept that I'll
second
leet and I will me say that if we start
if it's isn't going to be a consent
calendar Bill we will cease okay
representative Shu do you to speak to
your motion yes um I think this is a
pretty clear-cut Bill uh I imagine most
of our committee members have gotten the
hundreds of emails that were um
erroneously sent because so many people
had misinterpreted the bill but I think
looking at it uh it's pretty simple uh
pretty clearcut and I think it does um
mandate the fact that going to provide
transparency to the public for spending
does not have anything to do with
whether the governor can or cannot
declare an emergency just affords
transparency if one is uh put into
effect and I
agree does anyone else have a comment or
rhs if we're going to take action toor
modify
language in
anything we should have a reason to do
it that this is you know normally we we
joke and laugh and say oh you know
you're you're a you're a solution in
search of a problem this isn't even a
solution this is this is junk language
it doesn't this doesn't change anything
it doesn't do anything and frankly to
remove the words in order to ensure
transparency I'm not I have no desire to
remove that phrase from this because
that's ultimately the goal here at least
in my perspective in government is is to
promote transparency I so I I really
don't see the need to processes through
the House of Representatives when it
doesn't do a
thing and if I'm
missing what the thing is that this does
it all right continue leus you're
answering his question yes um I mean it
isn't a big deal but I think it does
simplify the language which there's some
value to that and um one way or the
other it's going to be processed through
the uh the house now that it's a bill so
I don't see that as a negative I mean I
don't have strong feelings on it but it
does simplify things and I support
it representative
rhs thank you madam chair I would like
to Echo representative Pearson's pretty
much exact words and I do have concern I
would I would like to hear what the
reason would be that anybody would think
that transparency is not of utmost
you I'm sh it sorry um would uh the two
members who have spoken uh be more
comfortable if uh we put forward an
amendment that would leave that uh
ensuring transparency and just take out
the phrase for informational purposes
Superfluous I'm seeing a yeah I don't I
I mean if you're specifically asking us
to me directly um yeah the that would be
fine I'd be happy to uh request that
Amendment and present it at a future EXA
yes I have some of the same concerns as
representative Pearson and rhs because I
think you know it is and transparency is
important and I don't think that the
changes made are that significant so yes
we
will let you get an amendment we will
continue this at our next executive
session which will be Monday the
24th okay we will do the pine tree Riot
Bill we will do this bill and whichever
of our other bills seem
appropriate thank you I'll have that
drawn up
okay and then that I think concludes the
executive session well excuse me
representative scitec you have a I
wouldn't mind seeing it on the
P others
feel I think what we were going to do
with that bill is check with the
proclamation
I'm I I'm I'm fine with that if I
can I guess we could chat right you
mind let's discuss the P the here's what
bothers me about it is 1262 this was you
could say U the Revolution was an a huge
Act of insubordination or lawlessness or
something but was founded in we hold
these truths to be self-evident it was a
noble if even if a rebellious act this
is a a group of 20 guys beat up two
years before the Revolution beat up a
lawful agent of the of the king uh he
was the authority this mob beat them the
20 of them beat the two didn't just send
them off or refused to obey I this is
just an act of lawlessness I don't I'm
not the least bit interested in
supporting
this and I know we got it something from
the chairman of the we Historical
Society but that doesn't particularly
not par persuasive compared to what I'm
what I've just said in my own mind
representative Pearson um I would have
liked to have seen uh Victim Impact
statement with a from the British Empire
in reference to this um
Bill
well if you guys want it that's fine but
I'm telling you I would support your
bill what's that I would support the
scitec maybe I'm G to CH this involves a
blurb doesn't it yes indeed it does okay
H I would like to make a motion Madam
chair yes um itl on the Pint ride bill
and I'll write the blurb and I'll second
it and uh the qu only reason I wouldit
on the blurb if I can continue is that's
kind of I spoke rather boldly about a
mob of 20 people beating up two agency I
don't know if that plays well in the uh
in a committee report but it's certainly
on my mind okay representative grota do
Motion in the past we have taken these
bills as um in a in a manner of asking
the
individual who put the bill forth forth
the bill to um consider a proclamation I
don't think that our request is
unusual and I think Falls in this in
line with other bills of this committee
has heard
before thank you representative laus um
I'm I'm of two minds on the one hand um
I I would support this I mean this was
uh part of uh rejecting the uh the
control of the the British crown over
the colonies and it did was a precursor
in some ways to the revolution however
um having a solid position of not
accepting uh special days bills and
rather urging people to ask the governor
to do the
proclamation is uh is you know there's a
good argument for that if we could do
that all the time and stop people from
putting these bills in well you can't
stop them but discourage um you know so
I
I I will probably support the itl
although um I do support commemorating
the underly
event anyone else representative Marsh
uh yes uh thank you madam chairman I
um like the idea of remembering the
history that happened before the
Revolution we often forget that but my
issue with this bill has to do with
separation of powers and that is that we
can issue a proclamation or a resolution
from the house but I think our ordering
the governor to do so is somewhat
problematic um so therefore I don't
think this bill should move
forward anyone else represent citec
that's an interesting thing
representative Marsh because I quite
forgot that that was one of my
objections to it we're ordering him to
do a specific act rather than carry out
a governmental policy and I'm just very
uncomfortable with that thanks
representative fellows um thank you
madam chair I I agree with
representative scitech my reaction to it
was that um since this was a fairly one
of many many events in our history that
are worth talking about and teaching
about that to Pro make a proclamation of
out of it Con I'm concerned with the
fact that it's an attack upon law
enforcement and given with some of the
recent
events that we just don't want to
promote that kind of
thing okay Rob Pearson were you you have
a comment
yeah echoing a multitude of very good
comments um we we've already heard the
other thing too is it's a time
constraint I mean we're talking April
14th here that through the legislative
process is is for all intents of
purposes tomorrow in in some ways so
even if we were to go through the the
whole process I don't know that we could
pull this off by April 14th frankly
so thank you representative uh leus and
then right I mean there um I take uh
representative Marsha's point on
separation of powers however there's
already lots of these in statute um I
would not be opposed to a bill in the
future to eliminate all of them but uh
uh there is a very strong and long-term
precedent of doing this sort of thing
thank
you not that the committee cares but you
won't be surprised to hear I would have
been a
tory
I'm shocked shocked to hear that all
right any other comments representative
goalie thank you madam chair and I'll be
real brief I agree with the words that
have been said I think
we've made this same issue and brought
this issue forward with other uh people
that come before this committee um and
this is a short time frame for this to
get done and through and I don't not
sure that it would happen so I think the
best way forward is for those indiv
idual to reach out to the governor for
Proclamation thank
you
representative thank you uh it might
seem like piling on because I agree with
everybody but um again it's another
interesting historical event or
character but with 655,000 pages of rsas
already on the books this is another
case where I don't think it rises to the
uh the necessity of passing into
law anyone
else representative Shou thank you um
I'm in agreement with everyone I just
want a
clarification is representative scitech
the one who made the motion and
representative Grotto made the motion
representative scitech seconded it thank
you any other comments
questions all right thank you in that
case the motion is inexpedient to
legislate by representative grota and
the clerk can call the role
representative
rhs
yes the clerk votes yes representative
yakovich no representative leus yes
representative algro yes representative
Bailey
no representative lonara yes
representative Santo naso yes
representative
goalie yes representative sh yes
representative Schmidt yes
representative Marsh yes representative
fellows yes representative
funno I'm sorry representative groa yes
uh representative O'Brien yes and the
chair
yes 170 no no oh no no no no no 152 I'm
sorry
gosh that's um itl passes 15-2 do you
gentlemen object to consent no no okay
thank you thank you we
will
um all right I have another motion if
you to hear three there's three yes yes
representative gr um on House
Bill I'm sorry I don't remember the
number I think it's 1213 the holiday
legal holidays yes yes I'd like to make
second okay representative gr a second
which Bill are we talking about House
Bill 1213 relative to legal holidays the
last one the last one that we just
heard no the first one after
lunch the morning
uh okay the last one that isn't gone
subcommittee do you wish to speak to
your motion representative gr yes during
after I heard this
um there is the difference between Duty
and
holidays and in my view voting is a
duty and is not a
holiday I don't and we've heard this
bill before in our
committee and has and we've we've had an
issue with this bill
concerning the um requesting
businesses to um take time off for their
employees for this
purpose um so for with that I just think
I don't think that this bill is does
what it needs to do and is no different
before thank you representative leus do
you wish to speak to your second uh yes
I I agree that um I have a problem with
the uh requiring the businesses to give
the people time off and I also don't
holidays any other comments
representative goalie and then
fellows thank you madam chair and I
think we also heard um and some of the
testimony we had here today and also
written to us that there could be issues
with contracts that are put out there
with employees and how they would be
enforced represent fellows thank you um
most of the government employees are
representative by a union so there would
be collective bargaining which would
really you know um supersede this
statute but uh those institutions do
have some hourly workers and this could
cause them to lose pay because if
they're hourly and and they're supposed
to take three hours off it it just that
would be a negative
impact represent saitech does anyone
have a sense are we going to continue U
early voting or is that was that just
Co because I mean if if we have a few
days early voting that just makes it
even less NE that's necessary but that
don't know that I believe that's hug up
in
Washington yes work Marsh M Madam chair
as a town moderator I would say that we
do not have early voting in the state of
New Hampshire we have absentee voting in
the state of New Hampshire and I believe
we reverted to the prior rules with the
emergency any other comments on House
Bill 1213 representative
roads thank you madam chair I
really just I probably not
necessary my thoughts are pretty much
what most people have already said I do
have concerns with um a time and a half
scenario that it very well could could
create um there was a a comment made
that you know tra you know trading off
this holiday for another what would
really be the the purpose of that
considering that you know election day
is is once a year you don't really trade
it off for a different day and for those
people that do have to work on on those
days um to say well these people over
here don't have to work because they're
government employees but you know you
work in an emergency room so sorry um
just doesn't really seem like the right
thing to do so I definitely would
support an itl on
this anyone
else yes representative parison thank
you madam chair um I I find I find it
interesting that the fiscal note is
loaded with zeros and into terminals but
under the methodology we're looking at a
at a potential State cost of 2 million a
year County County costs um The
Association of couny saying it's it's
almost a million dollars it seems to me
that there's a wellestablished fiscal
impact to to this idea I'm not really
sure how we in the you know in the boxes
above we we we seem to not have that
work completed so let's um you know
let's not forget that this this
certainly does come with a substantial
expense Pres sitech finish off with this
for me I've noticed that sometimes good
ideas are hard to put into good
legislation okay anyone
else all right seeing none the motion is
inexpedient to legislate by
representative brus seconded by
role
yes representative rhs voted yes clerk
votes yes representative Pearson yes
representative
yakovich yes representative leus yes
representative algro yes representative
Bailey yes representative lonara yes
repres representative Santo naso yes
representative goalie yes representative
sh yes representative Schmidt yes
representative Marsh yes representative
yes representative
groda yes representative O'Brien yes and
the
chair
yes
170 any objections to
consent okay good we'll put that one on
consent also and we don't have time for
another one even if we had another bill
that might possibly be suitable I'd like
to mention Madam chair yes sir I would
just like to point out I think we all
passed the onoff test with our
mics it's been a learning experience for
everyone
right
o Brian if representative samich doesn't
show up could you introduce the bill
questions
opening the hearing on House Bill 1123
and I'm calling on representative
O'Brien introduce the Bill thank you
madam chair uh it's my pleasure
introduce to you house bill 1123 allow
me to read it by title only directing
the department of administration
services in collaboration with the
Department of enery and the Department
of Transportation to support the
increased use of biofuels and biodiesel
for the state procurement needs and that
would conclude it Madam
chair thank
you all
Dodge thanks Madam chair um for the
record my name is Steven Dodge I am the
state Regulatory Affairs director for
the national biodiesel board and I'm
here to testify and support of House
Bill
1123 uh the bill would direct the
department of administrative services to
support the increased use of biofuels
and issue a report within the next two
years and just so you know the national
biodiesel board we're changing our name
shortly to clean fuels Alliance America
represents the biodiesel renewable
Diesel and sustainable aviation fuel
Industries our members play an important
role in state and National programs
aimed at reducing carbon emissions
displacing petroleum improving public
health and protecting the environment
many of our members are also members of
environmental organizations and are
supportive of state and local
initiatives to achieve a sustainable
energy future and I'm just going to
focus my few comments on just kind of a
high level a description of uh biodiesel
for those who may not be familiar with
it and by the way bioheat and biodiesel
are really interchangeable words uh
bioheat is used in heating applications
it's a trademarked word but it's the
same as biodiesel
uh and it is made from an increasingly
diverse mix of resources such as
recycled cooking oil soybean oil and
animal fats biodiesel and renewable
diesel are better cleaner fuels that are
available now for use in existing diesel
engines and heating furnaces and boilers
without
modification Nationwide some 3 billion
gallons was consumed last year and we
project use will exceed 6 billion
gallons by 2030 eliminating over 30 5
million metric tons of CO2 equivalent
greenhouse gas emissions annually with
advancements in feed stock use will
reach We Believe 15 billion gallons by
2050 and the liquid fuel heating
industry themselves has put their money
where their miles are in September of
2019 the liquid fuels industry in the
Northeast adopted the Providence
resolution which incorporates the goal
of using renewable liquid fuels for
heating at a B20 level which is a 15%
life cycle carbon reduction by the year
2023 b50 which is a 40% life cycle
carbon reduction by 2030 and net carbon
neutrality by 2050 industry took that on
by themselves reducing carbon emissions
now is more valuable than reducing the
same amount of emissions later and it's
really the same principle we learned in
high school a dollar invested now is
worth more than a dollar invested 20
years from now this is because earlier
red uctions limit the long-term climate
impact caused by the accumulation of
greenhouse gases this significant and
often overlooked principle is frequently
absent from policy discussions which for
example treat a reduction of CO2 today
with the same weight as a reduction in
2050 and this is simply not accurate and
it skewed the market to seek low
technology options which may not be
deployed for years or decades or ever at
all the increased use of biodiesel in
space heating applications and to
replace petroleum-based diesel in medium
and light duty trucks not only has
significant greenhouse gas benefits as
noted by researchers Across the Nation
but replacing Diesel with biodiesel also
results in a dramatic reduction in
co-pollutants sometimes called criteria
pollution or we call it tailpipe
emissions these dramatic reductions can
lead to significant health benefits in
the form of reduced asthma attacks
avoided work loss days and reduced
cancer risk
the use of B100 as a heating oil and
transportation fuel replacement can
reduce carcinogenic particulate matter
emissions by
86% and I'll wrap it up with this New
Hampshire is the only state in the
Northeast that does not yet have any
type of incentive in place to encourage
the sale and use of biodiesel
Massachusetts has an aggressive
incentive program part of its
alternative portfolio standard that has
resulted in the displacement of 46
million gallons of petroleum based
heating oil that program which is now
under review has the potential to double
that figure if the program as
recommended moves from B10 to B20 Rhode
Island Connecticut New York have all
passed recently passed bioheat mandates
Maine has had in place now for some time
a very successful pilot program that is
using biodiesel in dot heavyduty
vehicles and I understand that program
is expanding this bill is far from being
a mandate it simply directs the state to
support the increased use of biofuels
and state applications no mandate no
Force choices adoption of this bill
would be a first step small but
nonetheless important first step in
utilizing a cleaner burning affordable
available drop in fuel that immediately
reduces carbon emissions is primarily
domestically produced and requires
little if any burner or engine
modifications I hope this bill receives
favorable action in this committee and
as always happy to answer any questions
thank you madam chair thank you are
there questions representative uh
Schmidt thank you madam
chair F first a question you obviously
have prepared a written testimony can
you provide us with a copy of that I
certainly thank you so now my technical
questions about 16 years ago i chaired a
u a a study committee uh that was
referred to as the fat oil and grease
committee maybe you were still around it
maybe you were around at that time um
and one of the issues that was a
considerable concern because there was
already a lot of recycling of yellow
grease uh but Brown grease uh is a very
objectionable substance as you know very
nasty smelling and so forth and it's
nasty to deal with as well um so uh one
of the things things that uh that we
developed was that there was a process
for uh upgrading uh Brown grease uh use
um and I'm wondering whether uh you can
speak to us about where we are with with
regard to Brown grease because it's a
win-win situation to convert it to fuel
as opposed to dumping it yeah thank you
for that question representative I I
can't answer that particularly but I can
try to find an answer and get it to you
I can't say that there really is no
there's a lot of fat fats Brown grease
used cooking oil yellow grease that's
collected around here as you know
probably back when you were studying it
restaurants had to pay to get rid of it
now they get paid to sell it um uh but
there's no biofuel that is produced neat
biofuel around here there is a company
in New Hampshire that blends it but they
refine it out in New York and in Ohio I
think they have plants so the actual
processing of biofuel is not done neat
biofuel b00 is not done uh here there is
a facility in Newport and there's a
facility in Maine um but I can get the
specific answer to your question uh
they' they've come a long way in the
refining process thank if I may Madam
chair follow follow up thank you um so
you might confer with uh the lady who's
currently the president of keing State
College I believe Melissa Treadwell I
think is her is her name I mean have the
name wrong but I believe that's her name
she was involved in uh at the in this
thing at the time so she might be able
to help you thank you like to look at
that thank you I appreciate that thank
fra thank you Madame chair what um state
agencies and municipalities or um
districts use biofuels now do you know
can you share that with us um I don't
I'm sorry State entities like
municipalities or yes and agencies yeah
I I don't know of any in New Hampshire
um the only there's a couple of program
municipalities I know in the Northeast
that have pilot programs or established
program New York City all of their major
heavy duty Vehicles use biofuels those
big sanitation trucks you see that they
put the plows on in New York City they
all use biofuel for
transportation um there is a pilot
program that I mentioned with the main
dot uh the governor Massachusetts has
issued an executive order that requires
um I forget the schedule off the top of
my head but uh municipalities and state
agency not municipalities state agencies
to use bio bi more biofuel in heating
applications and transportation
applications and there are other
entities across the country that I know
use it in the midwest so forth follow up
so the um does not does UNH not use
biofuels in their trucks in their buses
they use methane from
the the um waste management plant which
is gas um yeah I mean they could I'm
just not aware of it okay I'm not
suggesting that it's not used I'm just
not aware of any last question please so
it's not really the increase of use
because it to me when I read this it's
I'm assuming that we use it right to
support the increased use of biofuels
it's just to support the use of biofuels
since we don't seem to be using it
anywhere that you know
of I I didn't draft the bill but um
question of semantics I guess I think
we're all coming from the same place but
thank you like to see more of it used
other
questions representative Maran then sh
it uh thank you this may be a bit of a
technical question but it relates to
whether we can actually use biofuel in
New Hampshire one of the problems I have
with my tractors the diesel fuel tends
to gel in weather light like we are have
right now how does biofuel do in in this
freezing cold water when it's treated
very well um it's used
in you north of South Dakota gets pretty
cold there um Maine um as far north as
Bangor I think that's where the part of
the dot program is expanding so when
it's treated um and it obviously has to
be treated as regular diesel fuel has to
be treated in cold weather as well uh it
performs
fine follow question can you tell me the
cost differential of the bofu versus the
standard diesel fuel so for those that
track it I know the um the name of the
agency in New York is escap it's an
nerta um tracks biodiesel and the prices
have been comparable um I think like
anything else from what I've told um it
it it fluctuates like crude fluctuates
which determines the price of petroleum
based diesel but it averages out
sometimes it may a little B bit higher
sometimes it may be a lower um there is
a federal $1 gallon blending uh tax
credit for blenders uh and So that
obviously does make a difference that's
an effect until the end of this year um
and we're hoping that it continues into
the future there is a provision in the
infrastructure bill that would allow it
to
you thank you sorry I didn't hear you
recognize me um
I'm aware that one restaurant at least
in conquer uh has been using U biofuel
for heating purposes and I believe he
has a local entity that uh processes it
for him uh are you aware of that and are
there any other private entities like
that that you know of in New Hampshire
well it it any type of processor or
refiner of bofs has to make meet
standards there are federal standards
for the finished product there are
standards for the the for the processing
um so I'm not aware of any and I could
be wrong but I'm not aware of any
facilities in New Hampshire um but uh
you know biodiesel got kind of a bad
black mark against it back 10 15 years
ago when people were blending it in
their garages and then their Sellers and
trying to put them in their Mercedes and
and and there was an incident with
school buses in Minnesota that I think
every everyone remembers and things
really went badly those days are gone um
the the refining requirements the the n
used spec requirements or the the fuel
spec requirements are ASM certified um
so and they're they're working on
requirements for ever increasing blends
of U of biodiesel so it's a pretty
wellestablished uh entity now um so to
answer your question directly I'm not
aware of anyone that produces locally
and and again um representative's
question earlier uh I'm not suggesting
it's not used at all um it is sold and
there are heating companies that use it
sell blends of B10 B20 uh and maybe even
higher Blends I just don't know exactly
who they are and who they sell to thank
you representative
Pearson thank you madam
chair I know with uh when I lived out in
the midwest the the
um the gasoline industry was was
experimenting with ethanol Blends and
things of that nature which had as a
result a modification of fuel economy
how does the biodiesel stack up as far
as fuel economy I know that we generally
don't measure big big trucks that use
diesel in terms of fuel economy it's
really function but is there a is there
any sort of measurable difference
between the Blends and just regular
diesel I'm not aware of any so what
you're referring to is obviously ethanol
which is a whole separate issue in uh in
gas powered vehicles and yeah it does uh
especially in the flex fuel vehicles
does affect fuel economy uh I'm not
aware of any um fuel economy issues uh
with and there have been a lot of uh
trucks that use up to B20 engines now
are certified up to B20 so you don't see
levels above that um but there have been
experiments um and testing with the oems
on higher Blends um and and I think the
most remarkable fact there is that
maintenance issues are down that's
certainly the case with home heating
furnaces because biodiesel Burns cleaner
um so requires less maintenance and
that's been the case uh to date with the
truckers as well but to your specific
question about fuel economy I'm not
aware of any economy fuel economy issues
with biodiesel it's essentially the same
molecule uh same product diesel is
diesel whether it's petroleum based or
biodiesel diesel representative
leus thank you um I understand this bill
is intended to promote the use of
biodiesel but my question is you aware
of any uh state law or regulation that
stands in the use of someone choosing to
use
it uh well certainly on the homeowners
level you passed a bill last year that
provides freedom of choice at the
homeowners level um I'm not I mean I
don't see anything in this bill that
forces anyone do anything just uh it's
it's not even a monetary incentive it's
just a state incentive to or guidelines
I guess perhaps is a better word to try
to uh encourage the use of biodiesel but
I don't know if I answered your question
followup yeah I'm I'm not asking about
what's in this bill uh the question is
um in addition to what this bill is
trying to do is there any anything in
current statute or in regulation that
you're aware of that would would uh get
in the way of someone choosing to use uh
biodiesel today no I'm not aware
anything no thank
you
scitech let's see Mr Dodge this is used
as a supplement to uh petroleum based
diesel fuels right it it's Blended in
yes okay yes this the question that I
have is does New Hampshire have any role
in this if this is a supplement why
don't we just ship it all to
Massachusetts or to Maine people that
are already doing this stuff because
it's not like they're overflowing with
this stuff they're looking for
supplies well supplies really aren't an
issue um I mean we believe that there
was three billion gallons of biod diesel
that was and renewable Diesel and
biodiesel that was produced and consumed
in the country yesterday uh last year uh
we're not we're certainly projecting
with future capacity of refineries and
crushed plants that are coming online
that uh supplies will not be an issue if
that's your question and maybe I missed
your
question you're not suggesting that
we're America can go to a 100% biodiesel
are you I'd love it if we went to 100%
biodiesel to be quite honest with you
but that's not going to happen in the
near future my point is that if it's 70%
diesel uh petro and uh 30%
bio why don't we just ship everything to
the people who are
using until we get up closer to uh
parody uh when we just ship it out and
let them do it why study anything just
send stuff to main uh Massachusetts for
them to use I don't think that's an
appropriate question for this one
sorry well yeah I and I'm I apologize
I'm not quite understanding your
question but I will say that whether
it's B2 or B5 or B20 or B30 it still
provides redu greenhouse gas reductions
immediately um we're not suggesting that
everyone switched to b00 by next week
thank you I hope I'm glad to hear that
are there any other questions from the
committee all right don't see any thank
you very much Mr Dodge representative
you
thank you madam chair and I'm the one
who should be apologizing because I
somehow totally missed the time slot to
come over here from my committee and I
apologize to the rest of the committee
for the delay I I should have been here
um let me just start out by saying that
um I was I got in interested in this
idea because of the fact that uh I
discovered that it is currently possible
for regular heating oil to be replaced
with
biofuels um I currently have and I've
had for a number of years uh fuels
delivered to me that are
B20 which means 20% biofuel versus 80%
petroleum base heating oil and because
we are live in New England we all know
that we all need Heating and we need
lots of it especially today so uh what
is the simplest thing for residents to
do if they want to become more uh free
of uh foreign suppliers for their
heating oil and also what they can do to
be more green with their own facilities
including heating which is a big chunk
of our energy consumption
so while I was getting B20 for my
heating oil I inquired with my supplier
I said well how high can you go uh that
that I don't have to do anything with my
furnace I don't have to make any changes
I have a tank in my basement I have a
furnace in my basement can I go higher
and being that I'm a scientist I always
like to experiment fairly on myself
first before I try other people so I
said well how high can you deliver fuel
to me with with be uh with a
biofuel and my supplier said we can
deliver 100% biofuel to you and it will
burn just fine in your furnace you don't
have to do anything and I said well give
me some of it and they said well the
problem is there's not enough demand no
not enough people know about it if you
can give us 30 more customers we'll
deliver it to you B 100 it's been done
in other places in the country and other
places in the world
especially as the previous spoke speaker
said uh the biodiesel industry Bou fuel
industry has reformed itself
significantly so now it has very strict
standards and uh so uh yes we can do
that and it will be just fine in your
furnace however when we don't have
enough demand for it otherwise we could
do it we've got plenty of supply and
that Supply comes from waste products
from soybeans and cooking oil and in
this state probably 50% of that cooking
oil comes from Portsmith probably from
the restaurants we have there if I have
to guess so so I was trying to
experiment on myself and I discovered
that in fact uh besides the need for a
higher demand there is no reason I
couldn't use B100 in my furnace and I
saw that as a big plus because it's less
polluting it's more green and it's
domestically grown it's a renewable fuel
why not do it uh so uh based on that and
based on conversations with various
people including Mr Dodge who I talked
to previously I discovered that uh you
know the the trucking industry is
already using most of them are using B20
already uh and there is issues with
weather conditions that have to be
treated but as far as heating oil for
residents there's really no obstacle uh
why you couldn't do it and if I can if I
can get 30 residents near Portsmith to
sign up I'll probably get a B100 Fuel
and try it out on my own furnace and
what was mentioned before was very true
my maintenance guy that does my furnace
maintenance every year while I when I
started using B20 he told me yeah your M
your F your furnace looks cleaner than
ever I have to do fewer maintenance
steps it's clean I'm surprised and and
he says I've seen this in many furnaces
that you used biofuel so uh I thought
that without being a mandate or anything
uh why shouldn't the state of New
Hampshire attempt to use more biofuel in
its own uh State dep part agencies and I
I got a message from um Rebecca from
Department of Environmental Services who
told me that there is something already
in St in on the books uh encouraging
that um uh I haven't had chance to talk
to her her comments came to me but this
bill was just meant to ask the
Departments that use um heating oil uh
currently to look into encouraging
looking at biofuels instead because I
think it would be an easier switch
without a whole lot of complications so
and it would drive up demand uh for that
product and it would help residents in
the state too who are looking into that
have more Supply available to them and I
can tell tell you from my own experience
that pricewise it's the same price as
heating oil so thank you very much and I
apologize again for coming too late to
this
hearing uh thank you representative
Pearson and then Le oh then goalie and
then Le thank you madam
chair one of the things that has been a
topic of discussion for the past few
years
now has been in reference to electric
cars and over the Ro fuel
tax when it comes
to this blend of fuel that is being used
in vehicles is this taxed the same way
as 100% Pro
or is there some sort of situation where
you you're not paying necessarily the
same federal tax or how how what's a tax
implication is basically what I'm
getting at here on on
this well if you know thank you very
much representative for that question I
have to say I'm not quite sure my imp
impression was from various
conversations that the current tax on
that fuel right now that trucks are
using is the same as they would pay on
diesel fuel regular diesel fuel but I
got to also say yeah Excuse me yes Mr
Dodge mentioned a dollar a gallon tax
cut or credit or was it a credit that
was a rebate for the processors maybe or
something is that for by diesel at the
correct that's a
feral tax credit but I think your
question is fuel
tax I'm not worried about that it's over
taxx tax same tax okay okay thank you
but I wanted to just say also that uh
since according to Mr Dodge and others
the the quality of trucking uh B20 for
example aside from treatment for winter
is pretty much identical to heating oil
and having lived in Germany uh for 17
years uh over there one of the biggest
problems was that de uh Mercedes cars
resid regular cars also use diesel as
well as trucks so what they did there is
in order to one is taxed and one isn't
because one's used for heating oil for
example and the other's Transportation
so they put a diee in in the in in the
fuel for trucks so if anyone tries to
use that for heating purposes by getting
it or other way around they would be
able to track it and and follow it sure
we do that now but I'm not aware that
there is a difference in the
tax thank you representative
goalie thank you madam chair I guess my
my question goes to why do we
need legislation requesting departments
to do this it would only make sense that
they would go ahead and do it on their
own if the price is the same but it's I
he of a lot less in maintenance
costs than using
regular oil products oilbased products
um I
I why why do we need why wouldn't they
just be transitioning over on their own
to save maintenance cost
alone well thank you representative for
the question uh like I said this is not
meant to be any kind of a mandate I
think what has happened over over the
last decade or so is that the quality of
this fuel has improved significantly and
now and price-wise is also competitive
so this is just a way of kind
of encouraging our the state agencies to
use it because it it's a less polluting
fuel so it's it's good for the
environment as well as reducing the cost
of the the health impacts and
environmental impacts of using regular
fuel so it's just meant to be an
encouraging bit of legislation but
that's about it thank you representative
leus uh thank you actually uh
representative goalie asked uh my
question almost word for word thank
you represent site Tech and then sh it
uh representative ssuch uh you there's I
have a question about this demand
business you've been talking about if
this is an a product that burns
identically and why when the truck rolls
up how do I even know what he's putting
into my tank what do you mean get
needing 30 more people you just do it
right well thank you uh representative
for that question in my case when I
tried to get it for my heating furnace
they they said well there's not enough
demand we cannot mix that blend for you
just exclusively As One customer now if
you had 30 other customers who wanted
one B 100 in the Portsmouth area they
could do
it I believe it sounds like the
distributor said if you have
enough customers so we can use a full
tank A full truck a truck load yes they
couldn't make a truck load just for me
yes representative why they just do it
it's an identical product I I don't get
it yeah but people people are cautious
about this and I think that's another
reason why I think the state of New
Hampshire should lead by example to give
people more confidence to know that this
is okay to do it I think a lot of people
are skeptical of it and
rightfully people don't know about it at
all yes rep oh representative saso
excuse me I actually work as a fuel
delivery guy and just to answer the
question um a lot of customers don't
want bof fuel in their in their system
because it has a stigmatism because of
its history and that's why they don't
just put it in
there even if it was a dentical product
that people don't want it so that's just
the
culture representative
Shu thank you madam chair um
representative I'm curious uh when you
were crafting this bill did you reach
out to these state agencies and uh ask
them if they've considered use and what
answers did you
get uh thank you representative for the
question I have to concede that I tried
but I hadn't made initial contact with
the people it was one of those topics
where nobody really knew who was
responsible and uh I I had a hard time
until Rebecca om reached out to me and
I'm glad she did and I will talk to her
more about this bill and her her General
comment was there is something on the
books already to encourage it are you
asking us to report to you how it's
working or what would you like us to do
so I will be pursuing it further but I
can't say anything more because I
haven't made those context yet thank you
thank you represent sonich if you find
out what the statute is that's
encouraging we would very much like to
know that I will certainly do that Madam
chair other representative Bailey
thank you um could you explain to me
what the 2050 and 100 of B20 b50 is that
a percentage yes it would be my
understanding is B20 is 20% biofuel 80%
regular heating oil thank you yeah and I
would like to point out something else
that there there is a use for the 100%
in various environmentally sensitive
areas let's say you're you're doing some
work in a sensitive area in national
park where you cannot possibly have an
oil spill and so if you have a fuel
that's 100% biofuel it's it's a good
choice to have when you're working in an
environment where you cannot afford any
kind of
contamination other question other
questions from the
committee okay thank you very much
representative samich thank you madam we
have a card from Griffin Mo from the
energy Department if there are questions
are there further questions from from
the
it good afternoon members of the
committee uh for the record my name is
Griffin robers from the New Hampshire
Department of energy here to uh uh
comment on House Bill 1123
um the department doesn't take any
position on the bill as it's written
however um internally in consultation
with legal counsel um there was some
concern or just looking for some
clarification I guess you could say on
section two of page two um specifically
starting on line five
to7 um where it reads that the
department of administrative services in
collaboration with the Department of
energy and the Department of
Transportation shall support the
increase of the use of biofuels in New
Hampshire especially biodiesel and
renewable diesel um like representative
ssuch I was down the hall and House St
when this bill initially started have
just slowly started to get a sense as to
what's being discussed um I think the
concern from the Department's
perspective is that it's kind of broad
at least on line six when it says Das
along with Department of energy and
transportation shall support the
increase of the use of biofuels I guess
what does that mean and it sounds at
least from the testimony it sounds as if
that's this language is meant to
encourage the use of it um by state
agencies that are listed here and their
uh Motor Vehicles their building Heating
and that type of thing but um just at
least on that line six a little bit more
clarity on that would be appreciated if
this bill um were to move forward um
certainly willing to take any questions
that the committee might have but as I
mentioned in House s I am three days
into this new job I can probably not
answer every question you might have but
but I will certainly I will certainly
try to follow up with the committee with
uh with uh answers for you and that
concludes my well thank you for that
that help if we need it is there are
there any
questions representative orrian or no
you're
okay I don't see any questions
immediately representative Pierce uh f f
first of all don't dump a lot of blood
in the water right before you uh go
swimming um we'll start with that um SE
I I see the point that you're bringing
here you know when you put the word
shall in
legislation that becomes a requirement
it's not a should it's a shall and
when especially in this lines 5 through
S when there's no picture painted as to
what compliance with that looks like it
would be unreasonable to expect any
agency to try to comply with something
that doesn't have a a parameter under
which to
comply so do you and I from the
Department of energy do you guys have an
idea of what that would should look like
or is this something that's just kind of
it was and first off thank you for the
question representative um this is just
an observation that was uh caught by our
legal council I think we would defer to
the prime sponsor as to any specific
language he would like to bring forward
to maybe address that concern but you
know obviously after hearing his
testimony it's meant it it sounds like
as if this legislation based on the
findings and everything um is meant to
put the state in a position to be a
leader I guess in using biofuels and
biodiesel and certainly understand um uh
the intention of doing so but at least
on line six you know if the state is
going to take a leadership role how I
guess anybody could understand you know
support the increase of biofuels in New
Hampshire does that mean putting
something on Twitter saying you know use
it you know does it mean that we should
be procuring it and it does say that a
little bit more down on lines uh
78 nine and 10 but you know just a
little bit more clarity on that initial
line I think would be greatly
appreciated representative
Shu thank you uh this is more a question
of the chair uh Madam chair do you uh
intend to send this to subcommittee and
if so would uh Mr Rober and their legal
counsel uh be willing to work with the
[Music]
subcommittee I'm not sure if it does go
to sub commmittee it'll be
representative
Pearson along with that um are we
potentially looking at a second
committee with this as far as I mean we
just looking at this from a
regulatory sort of please please and
thank you or does this really need to go
or I mean is that yeah or transportation
for that matter that's a interesting
question let me see if I can find out if
not um in any event I do have a question
if there is in statute
some requirement to encourage the use of
biofuels how are you complying with that
now yet and I you may not have that
answer but I'd love to have you report
on that no that's fine and that's
certainly something I can report back to
the committee on I just as the committee
you know asked earlier I think I'd like
myself
this is not an early bill so it is not
going to another
committee so I think it should go to
um you'll collect the information that
all of the people testifying have
promised to
send and if it's all right I'll send it
to the entire committee or do you want
me to just send it to represent send it
to the entire committee we can dispose
of it if it's Surplus representative
goalie thank you madam chair and we're
also going to have represent somuch or
maybe even our researcher out to see
because if this is already in statute or
something similar this may not be needed
and may not be that's already been asked
for yes
definitely okay any other
questions okay thank you very much M Mr
Rober thank you very much uh no one else
has signed up is there anyone else who
wishes to testify yes sir come forward
yourself
good afternoon Madam chair and members
of the committee my name is David rodrig
director of operations for the
Department of Transportation I may be
able to save you a little bit of time
searching for that other statute there
is statute 228 Cohen
24a in the administration of
Transportation laws
directed towards the Department of
Transportation specifically for our
motor fuel inventory and if it pleases
the chair I'll read a portion of that
law that's um relevant to the
discussion okay so section two says the
commissioner shall only purchase diesel
fuel that contains at least 5% biodiesel
as defined in RSA 362 a CO 1 a 1B except
if such fuel is unavailable or is more
costly than 100% petroleum diesel in
which case such purchase shall be at the
discretion of the commissioner so
basically this Law requires the
department to purchase biodiesel if it's
cheaper than regular diesel the section
goes on to say the commissioner is
encouraged to purchase diesel fuels
containing up to 20% biodiesel when such
fuels are compatible with the vehicles
served at given fuel Depots any
biodiesel blend purchased by the
commissioner shall be made available as
provided for in paragraph one and I'd be
happy to share this with thank you
that's very helpful if you would fill
out a pink card before you leave we'd
appreciate that
also are there any other questions yes
representative martians and fellows yes
thank you for coming before us that's
very helpful can you tell us uh how much
biodiesel or are we actually purchasing
biodiesel at this point in time or is
that not actually being done at this
point in time we are not we watch the
prices of biodiesel on a regular basis
but our fuel is fixed when we go out for
bid for lowest prices for fuel and we
accept bids for the the biodiesel as
regular as well as a regular Diesel and
fuel thank you madam chair um that was
my question but as a followup can you
tell me um anything about the cost
differential the cost differential
fluctuates and there's several ways that
that we look at cost with commodity one
is the the general cost so we subscribe
to an an opus subscription system which
gives us the price of fuel on a national
basis or at specific ports and so forth
but a big c a big part of the cost of
any commodity like fuel is a
distribution and that's what was
discussed earlier so um when we look
nationally biodiesel May rate favorably
with regular diesel but when suppliers
bid for those products they got to
factor in the transportation the number
of customers they have and so forth and
often um Regular diesel will continue to
win out on cost simply from a delivery
sense so so are you telling me that what
they're bidding is just um does not have
any bio in it because it's more it's
more expensive so they're not even
giving you an option they're just
telling you their lowest price for fuel
we get prices for both and we choose uh
the lowest price which historically has
been the straight
diesel okay and and you have no sense or
recollection of what the differential is
it fluctuates we go out to to bid every
year and a half to two two years
um and it's I I do not know that for a
fact actually could just give us is it
you know a nickel a gallon or a dollar a
gallon that would be helpful more of a
nickel to a dime or a quarter okay thank
you that gives us a better feel for
representative Marsh uh yes thank you um
has the department used enough biodiesel
in uh at some point in time in history
to give us an opinion as to whether
maintenance costs of the vehicles is is
actually less if you're using the
biodiesel right that that I cannot
answer I do know that we we have used
some some biodiesel in the past with
good results um the the newer equipment
has more modern uh emissions and I'm
simply not qualified to to answer that
question at this point um but it has
worked well for us in the in the past we
have done P pilot projects to burn it in
our furnaces as well which has worked
well for us in the past representative
Shu thank you madam chair um yeah my
question goes more to the
availability um I'm assuming that you're
going to have to go to like New York or
someplace to obtain this is that part of
the added
cost yeah uh again um when when we're
talking about motor fuel for for the
fleet the the diesel we put that out to
bid and the supplier can get it from any
location they may get it from Portland
Main they may get it from Boston they
don't usually go to to New York so I
think it is um again for the for the um
motor vehicle fuel it typically comes
from Boston I believe thank you all
right representative fellow you have
another question thank you um when you
put these bids out are you buying fuel
just for the State of New Hampshire or
do the counties and
municipalities take advantage of your
contracts the counties and
municipalities and nonprofits take ex
take advantage of the contracts so we
often Supply to school buses school
districts we often Supply to community
um fire departments police stations and
so
forth so have you ever given any thought
of of doing a contract that includes
both fuel types like like
100% petroleum and five or 10% diesel
because some of these other entities
might want to spend the extra money for
the
biofuel so that would be very difficult
for us we would have to maintain two
tanks two two separate pumps and in that
means any other
questions all right seeing none thank
you very much for appearing to answer
our questions is there anyone else who
testify all right seeing none I'm going
to close the public hearing on House
Bill
1123 and this will be going to
committee
than